that thus admitting he was the uphill
skier okay did it bother you
that one of now at the time you were in
charge of all ski instructors weren't
you no what was your what was your title
I was a ski patrol manager ski patrol
manager okay uh ski patrol manager did
it bother you
at a Deer Valley employee
an instructor
whose report you read
blame the male skier
even though he didn't see it that bother
you at all the time
I don't see Blaine here I can see thus
admitting that he was the uphill skier
no
did it bother you
Mr Graf
that
on this report
he never got the mail skiers contact
information
no yeah you're sitting there a day or
two later and he testified about it
and you read this report
and there's a there's a crash
that was serious enough
to haul someone down off the mountain on
a toboggan
and this man who's writing this report
never gets the male skiers contact
information that didn't bother you
that didn't bother me did it bother you
that
that Mr Christensen never gave Gwyneth
Paltrow's contact information
that bother you
that didn't bother me uh did it bother
you that Mr Christensen
never gave his contact information to
anybody
none of these bothered me because at the
time everybody skied away with the
assumption that everyone was fine
okay so your understanding was that
everyone skied away
even though
even though a ski patrol person named
Whitney Smith called
Terry Sanderson
off the mountain in a toboggan
in your definition that's everyone's
skiing away because they're all fine
Whitney Smith responded to Mr Sanderson
in a different location from where the
Collision occurred
so they all skied away
yeah let me ask you this
uh
this claims here
that a man with four documented broken
ribs two of which were separated broken
not just cracked separate
four
documented broken ribs
said he was okay to two other ski
patrollers that came allegedly came by
that Bobby would all
that's my understanding of what happened
did it bother you
that
allegedly
is this yellow over here
but a controller came by to check on
everyone
did it bother you that there was no log
of that patroller
no didn't bother you okay so nothing so
far has bothered you right
okay these are just the facts every
everyday life at your Valley right
yes okay uh
now
did it bother you
see this right here where my cursor is
yes
that Eric Christensen
after this crash
uh goes to lunch with one of the most
famous actresses in the world and her
family did that bother you at all
no I think that's standard practice for
ski instructors did it bother you that
three hours after lunch or so
that he then writes his report
that body of that concern you at all no
that's typical of what happens did it
ever occur to you that this instructor
might be covering up bad conduct
by himself to protect Miss Paltrow a big
spender at Deer Valley did that ever
concern you or bother you
no
did it ever concern you or bother you
that he might be covering a bad conduct
by Gwyneth Paltrow
no
uh didn't you basically Wink in a nod at
this bad conduct winking it on at it
can you define that you know what when
can an odd means
no
well actually you did was we had a
deposition another case but but when can
a nod
this I'm using it means you see
something wrong but you just wink at it
and go on and don't do anything about it
isn't that what you did here today
absolutely not okay
why wasn't this structure
terminated for filing a false report
that this is his report there's nothing
in it that's follows is that true that
you believe he wasn't funny because he
did nothing wrong
he did nothing wrong
correct okay uh and there was no
cover-up by durability correct
absolutely not great no further
questions
thank you Mr sakes
good to see you again Mr craft thank you
for coming back thank you very nice of
you
it was cooperating yesterday
I think I just need to go back to the
old technology again
Okay so
just want to ask you
ask you questions
oh yeah go ahead
I just want to ask you Mr graphic quick
question about the patrol log
published this we looked at it yesterday
with you defendants exhibit 26a
you were asked questions not today but
before you left the stand Yesterday by
plaintiff's cancel
about this uh bad boot uh entry here do
you see that I do see that and I uh um
do you remember questions about how that
was sort of a a minor issue and and he
was asking why that would be long but
other major issues might not be yes so
can you explain what is a bad boot it
and what would it require of a patrol uh
patroller Who Came Upon that kind of a
problem you know I'm not
exactly sure what this bad boot issue
was but um
it could be that the Buckle was broken
it could be that
as funny as it sounds could be there on
the wrong feet you know you see things
like that
um so there was some issue that Jess
responded to and it was as simple as a
bad Boot and made it required a toboggan
down the hill if someone had a
malfunction that they they couldn't get
down the hill yes okay so
um and then this this section here 1202
again I'll use this little laser pointer
1202 here
um
it
over in the nature of the injury
discussion it says here collision and
disorientation
do you know who wrote that
I don't know who wrote it
um whoever is Manning the dispatch is
the person who who puts these entries in
okay so would would it be fair to say
then that it would not be Whitney Smith
that wrote that it would not be Whitney
spit they're transcribing what Whitney
Smith is saying over the radio so
Whitney Smith was on scene two minutes
after the call came in
um
and then whoever was there
wrote down what she said Okay and she
said that she was on scene of a skier
collision with the patient experiencing
disorientation right and and the jury
has heard where her experience was and
you don't know anything further than
you've already told us about that
correct that's correct okay thank you
all right you were excused thank you
thank you is it there a possibility that
witness may be called back
very small okay so you're still under I
guess this trial so please don't discuss
the case with any of the other Witnesses
thank you
Mr Owens is your next witness ready
yes our next witness is Dr sure we we
need an easel and to set up for him to
draw and we may need a second to do that
okay okay
go ahead and set up
Dr Sharer
good morning come on forward here and be
sworn in as a witness
aware that the testimony you are about
to give in the case now before the court
will be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you God
you adjust your microphone and then
please
Please spell it all out for us
thank you
my name is Irving sure Irv ing last name
is s-c-h-e-r
thank you for being with us here today
Dr sure
um let's let's begin by just asking you
what you understand your role here to be
today
to teach the jury about biomechanical
engineering related to snow Sports and
particular skiing
and uh
do you have an understanding of what
plaintiff's biomechanical expert Dr Bame
has said about this case I have I've
read his deposition testimony and his
trial testimony so I do understand what
he's saying in the case yes okay and you
have opinions about his testimony is
that right that is correct I have
analyzed his biomechanical engineering
analysis so the jury will get to hear
your response to his analysis exactly
okay great so before we get to that
let's talk about your background in
training so they understand why
you and not me are on the stand sure
um
so uh where did you go to school
I did my Bachelor's of Science and
Engineering at the University of
Pennsylvania I majored in mechanical
engineering and applied mechanics
and then after undergrad I moved West
and I got my masters and my PhD at UC
Berkeley in the mechanical engineering
department and I had two disciplines
that I specialized in one was called
Dynamic systems that's how objects move
in space when forces are applied to them
and the other is biomechanical
engineering and that is the application
of physics and Engineering to the human
body in particular looking at how people
get injured and how to prevent injuries
and did you do a PhD thesis I did and
can you explain what you worked on sure
I was the last in the line of what we
called skeologists I studied the
biomechanics of Alpine skiing I created
load cells so those are devices that
measure the forces and I put them in
between the skis and the bindings and I
had different instrumentation on skiers
and it was the first time or at least
that I'm aware of that we were at anyone
in the scientific Community was able to
measure the forces and the body motions
of skiers from the top of the mountain
all the way down to the bottom and I did
this with beginners people who had only
skied two or three days in their whole
life all the way up to professional
Racers and so that's what I got my PhD
in and this is actually measurements on
the slope as people are skiing that's
right exactly yeah I'm measuring the
forces applied to the person and their
body motions as they're skiing well and
falling we did have Falls as well right
and so this is not just calculations in
some Ivory Tower but you're actually out
in the field looking at Hands-On work
which is quite difficult when you have
electronics and snow and water it was
challenging for sure
and do you also do any teaching
I did teach after I graduated with my
PhD I did a small postdoc in the biology
department at Berkeley and then after
that while I was working for a company I
taught at the University of Southern
California I was in the physical therapy
department on the Medical Campus and I
taught intro to biomechanics and I also
did research there at USC and then I
moved I now live in Seattle and I'm at
the University of Washington I have an
affiliate professorship there I'm an
associate affiliate associate professor
at the University of Washington and I
occasionally lecture but mostly advise
grad students
what about uh professional licenses do
you have any of those
I'm a registered professional mechanical
engineer in California Washington and
Alaska
and then in terms of
professional societies these groups of
people that get together to research and
work on a certain field are you
connected to any such organization I am
and what are those
I am chair of a group called ASTM f27 if
you've ever gone to a ski shop and
purchased ski equipment or rented ski
equipment and they set your bindings
what some people call Din settings
that's based on the standards from ASTM
and I'm the chairman of that group we
also do other snow sports equipment I
represent the US for snow sports
equipment safety at the international
standards organization so the iso so if
you go over to Europe you'll have the
same release and retention settings for
your skis your your bindings won't pull
off your skis they use the same
standards that we've developed here in
the U.S
I'm also president of a group called The
International Society for snow Sports
safety and that's more academic than the
other two organizations I was mentioning
we call it I triple s i Triple S is the
Premier organization worldwide to
present and publish your snow sport
Safety Research and we have members from
all over the world Switzerland Korea
Norway obviously the US Canada Australia
New Zealand it's uh it's quite a great
group and it's really the group that
helped develop ski binding standards
so you do some research on
the safety of snow sports like skiing
correct that is my main focus of my
research ever since grad school and I've
continued to do that now and then you if
you also value a cases in a litigation
context is that right I do about
15 20 of my work is forensic work the
rest is research and development
so most of the time are you doing
research to to try and
improve the safety of skiers on the hill
yes and I should say it's not just snow
Sports I work in other Recreational
Sports areas water sports mountain
biking other areas too but snow Sports
is my my favorite my passion
so let's explain to the jury what
biomechanical engineering is just
because we could use a refresher
ensure biomechanical engineering is the
application of physics and mechanical
engineering to the human body but in a
forensic sense it's what links the event
to the injury so if you have some type
of event and there's forces and motions
in the event in the accident the forces
are applied to a person there's internal
forces on the like in their body at the
joints or something like that
the amount of force and the amount of
motion it takes to create damage to the
body that is biomechanical engineering
how is that different than medicine
they're both dealing with the human body
but what's the difference sure the
medical field tends to take the injured
person figure out what's wrong with them
so diagnosis and then try to get them
better so treatment with an eventual
outcome so most medical training is
after the injury as opposed to what
forces and motions create the injury we
like to think of ourselves on different
sides of the injury
can biomechanical Engineers determine
the forces required to produce fractures
of bones in the body
yes there's a lot of research on that
and that's one of the main areas for
biomechanical engineering
so is there scientific literature that
describes the forces needed for say rib
fractures there is yes and you're
familiar with that literature I am yes
and uh
let's let's maybe ask a specific
question about that literature given
your knowledge of it does a 70 year old
man need to fall on his side uh with his
elbow between him and the ground to
cause refractures
no so there have been a number of
scientific studies mostly done by
biomechanical Engineers but there's
other scientists who've looked at this
as well and what they do is they take
cadavers or portions of cadavers and
they apply forces to them sometimes
they'll swing a pendulum into the side
of a cadaver or into the front or
they'll have a plate a very heavy
weighted plate contact the person arm
down arm up at 45 degrees or they'll
drop the cadaver in different
configurations and then they'll see what
injuries are produced and so when
they've done this in particular for
chest impacts what we find is you can
get lateral rib fractures according to
the biomechanical engineering literature
you can get lateral rib fractures with a
an impact to the side with your arm down
or with your arm up but you can also get
lateral rib fractures from compression
so front to back compression
of the chest so if I press my chest in
like this what happens is the ribs
actually Bend out on the side and that
can create fractures on the side and
that's quite common as well so rib
fractures are not just from side contact
it can be from front to back compression
as well
so
um
let's get to
um What You Did In this case so what did
I ask you to do in this case
basically you asked me to evaluate Dr
Bam's biomechanical engineering analysis
to see if it was accurate and correct
and
what material did you review I think you
already mentioned you read his
transcript and you watched his trial
testimonies that I did I did yes and
maybe for the jury in case they need a
reminder he had that green screen in the
back of him right just the talking head
speaking from Florida I think that's
right right and so let's uh just start
with his analysis do you agree with it
I do not I do not agree with his
analysis and maybe uh before we explain
why just give us a sense of what you
what you understand his method and
Analysis to be
sure
um as I've gone through what he
testified to in his deposition in the
trial looking at his calculations and
what he's done
to me there's two parts to his analysis
the first is calculations to show that
Miss Paltrow had to land on Mr Sanderson
in order to get the rib fractures that
he got
and then there was a second part that
basically said
um because Miss Paltrow had to land on
Miss Mr Sanderson that could only happen
with Miss Paltrow hitting him from
behind it couldn't happen any other way
it was impossible so that's my
understanding of the the kind of the two
parts the main parts thank you we'll go
in those go over those in more detail as
you looked at his analysis you read
everything that he read correct I did
and did you read even more than that I
had additional depositions that's
correct of the various people that were
at the scene of the accident that's
right
um
so
let's get one thing out of the way do
you agree with Dr Bain that Mr
sanderson's rib fractions did not occur
during the initials here to skier
contact yes I think that that's correct
there's no disagreement at this point at
least from the testimony I've heard the
skier skier portion where they first
Contact no matter which version we have
did not create the rib fractures I don't
think anyone thinks that at this point
so that's good we agree
and
um
in terms of just a quick overview before
we go into his calculations which you
can explain to the jury
do you believe that Miss Paltrow's
account and I should say are you
familiar with her account I am and you
heard her trial testimony I did and read
her deposition
do you believe her account of the
Collision is consistent with biome what
you know about bio mechanical
engineering object
goes beyond the scope of this expert
witness
would you please approach the pension
sure
okay so let's go back to that question
I was asking you
in your opinion is Miss Paltrow's
account consistent with what you know
about biomechanical engineering yes it
is and maybe another way to put that
um is is it consistent with the laws of
physics it's the same question yes yeah
exactly Dr Bain the jury heard talked a
lot about Newton's laws and the laws of
physics applying those to the evidence
in this case and again in your analysis
as you apply them Miss Paltrow's
uh account is consistent with those
objection lights Foundation
overruled
that's correct her Miss Paltrow's
version her her scenario is consistent
with the laws of physics and what we
know about biomechanics
and then the account that Dr Bain gave
that is based on Mr Ramon's account
um is that consistent with the laws of
physics
I do not believe it is and I can
as we get into it yes okay great we'll
we'll explain that let's
let's um
go to Dr Bain's calculations so you can
explain to the jury
um your analysis of those I'm we can we
have an easel and as I understand it you
you would like to kind of draw so that
you can show them what the equations
mean is that correct that's exactly
right okay so I'll grab the easel and
then that board
we can't block the judge
judge where do you want this season
he's gonna also need to see the screen
so is it okay if we put it
right here are you going to be able to
see that
I can't see it but it's really more
important that the jury see it so I'm
fine with that okay
if you're okay with the judge you can
do this
okay so I'm gonna pull up
something that Dr Bain pulled up uh in
his deposition
do you remember seeing the these
documents and for the record and for
Council these are
um
the notes in exhibit three of Dr Bain's
deposition
thank you
sir I missed the question there yeah no
you're fine so I'm just pointing you
before you uh what these are not
admitted exhibits though yeah I'm not
asking them to be admitted they were
just shown in Dr Bain's deposition so
we're showing them here as well
okay but not in his trial testimony
he's responding to these you said
deposition
he also showed it in his trial testimony
oh trial deposition yeah
yeah let's just say direct things to the
judge but I I recalled I recall this
being flashed the strongest deposition
or during his trial testimony
okay thank you Dr sure so you recognize
this page
I I do and I was just describing it this
was shown in Dr Bain's trial testimony
correct that's correct and he explained
that these are his calculations that's
right okay and there's another page as
well I think it's the one just before it
correct that's correct this is where he
starts the calculations for the ribs
we're concentrating on the ribs here
because that's what he says determines
how the the accident happened he said
the head injury doesn't matter for that
it's only the ribs okay great so since I
have very little idea what's going on
there and you do maybe explain to the
jury what's going on sure can we go to
the page before this sure
and maybe if you it's just a little bit
hard to hear sorry is that better yeah
okay A little better yeah thanks
um so he's using some basic equations
for what we call the center of Mass to
figure out what happens when someone
falls to the ground Center of mass is if
you were to balance someone on your
finger the point that you'd hold them at
so that they stay balanced
usually a little bit below your belly
button kind of midline front to back
midline left to right and so if you took
the person's all the person's weight all
their person's mass and put it into one
point that would be the point that
you're interested in so that's what Dr
Bame is doing in these calculations is
he's using that point for Mr Sanderson
and this first part here
where he has this
that's an equation x is positioned so
he's saying there's a certain distance
that Center of mass Falls and you can
see that over here that's three and a
half feet or he does it in meters
1.0668 meters so Center of mass falls to
the ground he's saying that there's no
initial
falling position that that's fine no
initial falling velocity V is velocity
and then he has one half acceleration
times time squared and that equation is
correct acceleration here is the
acceleration from Gravity so what he's
saying is Mr sanderson's fall to the
ground for the center of Mass from three
and a half feet
probably about right
hits the ground within and he calculates
the time he solves for time
0.466 seconds
so that's the first part of that which
is great
the problem comes in that he then says
the velocity at contact is one half
acceleration times time
and that is absolutely wrong that is not
the velocity at contact the velocity at
contact
is just the acceleration times time so
he has this extra half
and it was unclear to me why that would
be there to start and I'm not sure why
you put that in but it creates problems
for his calculations and his opinions
moving forward if we can go to the next
page I can explain that
so these are his equations if you
remember in his testimony he said 4 000
Newtons and that's an engineering unit
in in metric for Force four thousand
Newtons is roughly 950 pounds I think in
English but Newton's is fine over 4 000
Newtons you get the rip fractures
so what is this equation here I'll show
you that and then explain why that one
half makes a big difference so that
equation there comes from at first
kinetic energy
label that as ke which is equal to
one half
mass times velocity squared for that
Center of mass
and then he's saying okay Mr Sanderson
as he hits the ground has a certain
kinetic energy that energy has to go
somewhere
so what happens is a force is applied
from the ground to a center of mass and
he decelerates over some distance so you
can see here he has three inches written
here that that's important so
this kinetic energy has to be taken up
by some Force
over a distance that's some amount of
work
and that will equal
kinetic energy and then he divides both
sides to get the force
the distances cancel on this side so the
force on Mr Sanderson is one half
mass times velocity squared divided by
distance and that's exactly what we have
here we have one half
Mass velocity squared and distance
now
remember he's doing this in metric so
that 136
that is in kilograms
that's equal to about 300 pounds
so here he has
missed Miss Paltrow and Mr sanderson's
Mass put together so in this fall he's
saying okay the kinetic energy of both
of them
is needed here
during contact
but
can we go back to page five
um he uses the velocity here
2.29 that has the one half in this so if
we go to the next page yeah so you can
see he's using the wrong velocity what
happens is if you use the wrong velocity
in here let's do
beams as call this wrong
so what you get is one half mass times
one half acceleration times time
there we go divided by distance and
there
correct
is one half Mass
acceleration times time squared so that
one half goes into this equation what
does that mean that means that this half
gets squared it becomes 1 4.
so the force that
Dr beam calculated for this Landing was
actually one-fourth of the force he
should have calculated he was off by a
factor of four so it shouldn't be four
thousand six hundred and eighty Newtons
it should be eighteen thousand six
hundred and some Newtons actually I have
it here
um 18 678 Newtons so he's off by quite a
bit and if I made Dr sure what this is
obviously all uh uh at least new to me
and maybe new to some jurors what in the
end uh is the takeaway there if there's
that much of a mistake so there's
there's two things one is if there were
eighteen thousand Newtons applied to Mr
sanderson's chest we would expect much
worse injuries the biomechanical
engineering literature for much less
than that has many more rib fractures
internal injuries all sorts of things we
don't see any of that for Mr Sanderson
but the real takeaway and the importance
in this case is the mass here so because
he does the one quarter he needs the
mass oh he needs the mass to be 136
kilograms now if you redo the
calculations correctly
with with just Mr sanderson's Mass so
Mr Sanderson is about
80 and a half kilograms or roughly
177 pounds at least according to
the medical records if you do the
calculations with the correct equations
and only his Mass
you get over 4 000 Newtons when he lands
actually
you get
11 056 Newtons so if you were to fall to
the snow
using Dr bame's calculation method the
correct way
then just Mr Sanderson falling not miss
Paltrow involved at all he could get rib
fractures
this is not quite correct overall
normally we use what's called effective
Mass so all of Mr sanderson's Mass
wouldn't go through his chest maybe
there'd be some force on his legs if he
hit his head some force on his head we
typically would say maybe 50 of his Mass
would be appropriate for Effective mess
so instead of the 80 kilograms we would
do
and actually I should put over here this
winds up being eleven thousand
Newtons and if we do the 40 kilograms
instead for Mr Sanderson so
um
and that's uh
and we use the correct equation we get
sorry I don't do the math in my head
um
500 Newtons approximately
what this means is Mr Sanderson can
follow the ground without Miss Paltrow
landing on him
and sustain the rib fractures according
to Dr bame's calculation method
so if done correctly he cannot say his
opinion that Miss Paltrow had to land on
Mr Sanderson to get the rib fractures
which means that this goes through the
rest of his analysis so the rest of his
analysis is wrong
so this is really critical that one half
that that he did for the velocity
the wrong velocity really through the
rest of his analysis into question so Dr
sure there's a lot more we could say
about the calculations I'm sure and you
would you would approach it differently
than he did correct that's correct but
given the way he did it if he did it
correctly you're saying that the um the
conclusions that he came to are
inconsistent with his opinion that's
correct yes okay exactly
Okay so
um yeah
okay Doctor let's talk about
um
let's talk about skier skier collisions
you've as you explained earlier done
research to
understand what forces are like on the
ski slope so
um in this case how how would you apply
what you know about physics to
understand the claims about this key
Collision
sure I would apply Newton's laws to the
contacts the different versions of the
events and see
what makes sense how it would unfold do
the physics of the contact that's being
testified to makes sense is it
self-consistent
and this this may be another opportunity
to draw some pictures if you need to so
feel free to if it will help you but
um you were talking about the center of
mass earlier how does that
concept factor into how you would
evaluate the evidence in this case sure
yet if it's okay to draw again you may
thank you
and I can see where you're drawing
nice perfect great
and if you need more uh board or Pages
we have them now is that correct
distance right okay yeah great go ahead
so the thing to know with Newton's Laws
Force equals mass times acceleration if
you have some and I'm going to draw two
versions of a skier and I'm not the best
Pictionary player I'm going to draw a
top-down version and I'll draw a side
version so let's start with the top down
so if we have a skier
and here's the skier's head and here's
the skier's nose and then we have two
skis
the center of mass would be as we
mentioned looking down somewhere around
here
now if you have a force that goes
through the center of mass so say the
force
goes through
then the person will accelerate
in this direction they'll accelerate
along the line of the force
but what happens when you have a force
that doesn't go through the center of
mass
it'll create an acceleration going in
that same direction but it'll also
distance here it'll also create a torque
which is equal to the force times the
distance that will cause the person to
rotate
and that's really important because if
the force does not go through the center
of mass there's always a rotation
so if you're hit on the this looking
down this would be the right side then
the person is going to rotate
counterclockwise in this image the same
thing is true if we look at a skier from
the side
so here we have our
skier
and here's their pelvis and
Center of mass
for ski boot
and if the person for example
has a force applied
below their Center of mass
then there's again some distance that's
going to create
a torque and a backward rotation so that
the person moves
backward
and falls back
um
there's two things to note with this for
skiing in particular that's different
than most other events
skis have releasable bindings so if I'm
looking at the side view
the boot is held in
by a heel piece and a toe piece and so
if you have someone pitching forward if
the ski slows
the person's Center of mass moves
forward it'll create a torque on the
boot and it'll release
the heel of the boot
and for someone of Miss Paltrow size
that could be
anywhere from well it's approximately
143 foot-pounds so 143 pounds acting
over a foot
um same thing is true for the top down
view if we look at the toe piece for the
binding if there's a torque
on on the skia twisting torque
the ski will also release from the boot
and for someone of Miss Paltrow's size
it's about 37 foot-pounds so in front of
the boot if there's 37 pounds one foot
ahead it it'll release if it's two feet
ahead it's half that value so roughly
17. so these are the principles that we
need to understand the mechanics of an
impact in a fall so when we apply those
principles to this case what conclusions
do you draw
sure the first is that Miss Paltrow's
version of events is consistent with the
laws of physics and how people move and
rotate
and uh
what about Mr Ramon's version
for Mr Ramon's version I couldn't get it
to work
and there is it doesn't match with the
laws of physics the the complete part of
his testimony just doesn't fit and so
can you explain why it doesn't fit
uh sure so
um Mr Ramon's version
oh sure yeah go ahead
so uh in Mr Ramon's version
he says that he sees Miss Paltrow
contact
UM Mr Sanderson squarely in the back
and he says that it's in the middle it
couldn't be anywhere in the middle than
if he tried or if she tried and then
also that she wrote him down I think the
quote was something like in his
deposition he says
like she wouldn't couldn't have been on
his back any more than if he had
strapped her to his back something like
that
so as they're going down in Mr Ramon's
version uh Mr Sanderson goes spread
eagle
um arms out legs out and the key for me
is that Mr Sanders I'm sorry Mr Ramon
says that the inside edges of those skis
that are going into this V catch and Mr
Sanderson stops on a dime
and if that were the case then miss
Paltrow would keep moving and well maybe
I should draw sure go ahead if it will
yeah I think so
okay so uh I'm gonna try to draw a
top-down version of this so if we have
Mr Sanderson
and
here are his skis
and then I'm going to use a different
color for Miss Paltrow how about blue
Miss Paltrow
contacts him
from the back
and now
this is the same whether one ski is
between his or or both skis
the skis are apart it's a little bit
different so we can get to that in a
minute but if if her skis are between
his let's just say
than when he falls
and here is his
so they're moving in this direction
obvious but I want to make sure that was
clear so now we're still looking down
here is Mr sanderson's back here's his
head
here's one arm
here's another arm
here is one leg the other leg now
remember Mr Ramon says that his skis are
in a V
spread eagle so now
if that were to happen then
he stops very quickly and Miss Paltrow
is going to remain at in contact
somewhere around here and her skis
are going to stay underneath Mr
Sanderson
when that happens it's like the center
of mass continuing to move forward while
the skis
slow rapidly which creates an upward
Force at that heel it's going to create
a heel release
but as you heard in the testimony all
the skis were on it doesn't work it
takes actually very little Force for
this to release the heel piece to
release in a scenario like this so it
doesn't match with physics and it's the
same way whether one ski or both skis
are in between okay so how do you know
this especially about the bindings
releasing
how are you confident about that my
experience I mean I've seen tons of
binding releases I know how bindings
work
it's uh it's just physics right and
you've specifically done research on
binding releasing oh yes yes and and uh
you said earlier that there were other
scenarios the skis maybe between Mr
Sanderson skis maybe they're diagonal
did you do evaluation of all those sort
of scenarios and did any of those work
no I couldn't get any of them to work so
um the the key is either she would come
out of the bindings or she would be
stuck on Mr Sanderson she wouldn't be
able to move past him if her ski stayed
on in various versions of this I don't
know how she continues to move downhill
the 10 feet that Mr Ramon said she wound
up if her skis are trapped underneath
him and would you expect her to get an
injury in any of these scenarios well
certainly there's that potential yes a
lower extremity injury for sure if for
example her legs get stuck in one of the
scenarios you mentioned right so for
example if her ski is rotated out to the
side going in that V with one of his
skis the other whether it's on the
outside or in the inside can't lie kind
of
well so if her ski is on the outside his
ski is going to push her ski out
if this is her ski
as he's as he's falling and moving into
that V configuration it's going to
go from this position
to here and it's going to push
her ski outward
um which I would expect would create a
toe release a twisting release of the
bindings because it actually takes about
18 pounds of force between 15 and 20
depending on how her bindings would be
set so very little Force to release that
toe piece but even if it didn't release
then her ski winds up getting trapped by
his and she can't move for forward so
and in many of these scenarios her leg
would get twisted in a really odd way
that would likely create injuries okay
great I think you can sit down again and
now what I'd like to do is
ask you about
whether you were involved in creating
any animations that would help the jury
understand your opinions in this case
yes and your honor if I may ask for
permission to show the witness these
animations so that I can play some
Foundation he can use them to shoot
yeah we reserve our same objections on
these animations your honor understood
why don't we take a recess while they
straighten out the technology and then
we'll be back
you can step down whatever you need to
do thank you
everything working now yeah sorry that
we had plugged it into the course okay
doctor sure is using the room okay
all right
why don't you go ahead and have the jury
come in
Dr Sherry you can take the stand
we're just waiting for the jury
are you not enough yes yeah she's
monitoring the audio
foreign
thank you Mr Egan you may proceed yes
your honor may I approach to show the
way in this animation
so this animation is number five correct
it is called close up
and I'm gonna play it for you
is this one of the animations that you
helped prepare oh sorry counselor
sure which number is it
number five
it's called close-up
and
22 seconds
so again Mr shirt uh Dr sure you're
um
maybe explain to the jury your
involvement in creating this animation
sure I worked with Brian Brill at
Mountain graphics on the
impact and fall portion of this
animation it's not meant to represent
exactly what happened but generally the
idea of one of the family of ways this
could happen in Miss Paltrow's version
we don't know some of the exact details
of how they contacted how long they
interacted but it gives an illustration
of what it what I'm thinking my
understanding of
her version where they contact she's
contacted from behind and then fall to
the right
and does the animation make certain
assumptions about
various facts and testimony in the
record in this case
yes it does okay and you can explain
those to the jury as we go through it
sure yeah and the animation will help
you explain what you've said earlier
about my mechanics applying biomechanics
to this case right exactly okay some
permission to publish this to the jury
your honor
I'm just we assert our ongoing objection
to the animations or cartoons they uh
black Foundation uh distort the reality
and our incomplete
so animation number five is received for
demonstrative purposes only to help this
witness uh explain his testimony thank
you your honor
so Dr sure I'm gonna
let you
take the reins here and use it as you
need to explain okay I think you're
right uh your honor we also object to
the extent that this witness hasn't
testified to any of the placement of any
of the other skiers or or bodies in this
animation
Mr Egan is that relevant to this
witness's testimony of the other skiers
no he's going to talk about the
Collision in itself so you should ignore
any of the other skiers that are shown
in the animation
okay so you can reverse it Dr sure to
just uh before the Collision so you can
we can focus on that and explain
what you mean
um to show by this animation maybe I can
how do you
you could press play again and it will
get to it
okay great
so
take us through
um if you would Dr sure what uh
um this animation shows from your point
of view as a biomechanics expert sure
um the first thing that you should be
aware of is that this is Miss Paltrow's
version of the events so Dr sure sorry
to interrupt you just maybe pull your
mouth sorry sorry about that the first
thing to be aware of is this is Miss
Paltrow's version of the events so
that's what we're showing here and as we
move forward I'll talk about the physics
kind of like what I drew earlier with
the center of mass and the rotation and
that's the idea that's what went into
this but again this is not exactly what
happened this is just one of the
possible ways it could have happened
so
um
we have Miss Paltrow in Black Mr
Sanderson in the blue
as they move forward in time
it's her testimony that
his skis slid between hers
there we go she felt a contact directly
in the back along her back it sounded
like her buttocks as well
it the person was grunting pressing
against her but they were on their skis
for a period of time
if in the situation he's also moving to
skiers right which is in the left in
this image that will create remember I
had the force that was offset from the
center of mass that's going to create a
rightward motion for her but also create
some initial rotation now in in this
portion there's a number of
possibilities she could be adding weight
to her right ski because of the contact
from Mr Sanderson when you ski if you're
in let's just take a snow plow or what
my kids call Pizza position if you wait
the right ski you turn left so if she
waits the the right ski here more
because of the contact she's going to
turn counterclockwise
the contact from Mr Sanderson if it's
more to the right will turn her
counterclockwise so as they're moving to
the right here there would be some
counterclockwise rotation and here her
ski can catch or she could pitch to the
side or they could both pitch to the
side they could both lose balance we're
not sure what happens but as they're
rotating they're continuing to fall and
Miss Sanderson Miss Paltrow's version
has them spooning essentially as they're
coming down together which would make
sense if their legs got caught up if he
was contacting her below her Center of
mass where his right leg was contacting
her right leg her thigh in that area
also consistent with Miss Paltrow saying
that her knee her right knee was splayed
open at the end and she felt right knee
discomfort that that all could happen
there
so as she's rotating and he's rotating
counterclockwise they fall to the side
now
at this point here in the animation
I guess maybe the next frame
if I can do it
Mr Sanderson lands on his right side
maybe the right back it's hard hard to
say if he lands on his right side kind
of like Dr bam said you know he needs to
land on the elbow that can happen that
can create lateral rib fractures
but that's not the only way his arm
could be out he could land on the side
and create lateral rib fractures he
could land on his side and a little bit
towards the back and Miss Paltrow could
land on him she could be fully on him
maybe
um with her her buttocks or her back or
some portion of her Mass compresses his
chest front to back and that can create
his rib fractures there's a lot of
different ways this could happen I can't
tell which one of those is right
but all of those are consistent with her
version of the events
as they hit the snow they would continue
to move forward until friction slows
them down
and it's also important to note we
haven't talked about the head injury but
hitting the back of the head or the side
of the head he could have his head
turned all of those are possibilities
for him to contact his head on the snow
so that's not inconsistent as well
would it be helpful to show it in real
time you've been doing it kind of slow
motion which has been also been very
helpful
maybe maybe start from this beginning
and just play it
objection lacks foundation for
trajectory speed and direction
overruled it's a demonstrative of this
witness's testimony only all right thank
you
okay sorry yeah go ahead doctor this is
from the the beginning and if there's
anything you want to comment on as it
happens feel free
I think that accurately reflects the
version that Miss Paltrow testified to
that matches the laws of physics and
biomechanics as I understand them and
would it be helpful to show there's one
other animation that has a little zoom
in from the other angle would that also
be helpful I think yeah I can't hurt
let's show that then
we'll approach your honor for that
what's the number of this animation
this will be number
four it's called zoomed inside
what was the last one number five
oh that's right
yeah thanks
okay wait just a second
okay Dr sure so I'm playing you number
four the zoomed in from the side version
were you a part of
creating this version as well yes this
is the same animation but from a
different camera view
will this animation also help you
explain the same things you've been
going over with the jury it's the same
thing sure yeah I think it also
visualizes it illustrates my opinion
okay
your honor permission to show this uh
animation subject to the same objections
by the plaintiffs the animation four
zoomed inside is received for
demonstrative purposes only
four doctor sure maybe since we've
already gone through this this slow
motion let's just play this one from the
start and then you can add anything that
you can
provide to the jury from this angle sure
here let's play first and then there we
go
until the contact point
it's coming up here we go
there's contact
fall to the right
this one doesn't show the rotation quite
as much and we don't know the amount of
counterclockwise rotation as well there
could be a little there could be more or
less right we're not sure but if you if
you go backwards a little bit
in into the moment of the Collision
this one maybe
shows does this one show the skis coming
between the skis
yes it does
better visualized in this one yeah and
and again what's the significance of
that in terms of how the mechanism of
the Fall occurs
well that's Miss Paltrow's testimony and
it works for the physics of them falling
and rotating slightly counterclockwise
frankly if it wasn't both skis if it was
one ski between hers the kinematics
would be the same for example if his
right ski were on the outside of her
right ski it wouldn't change the general
kinematics this is generally and I keep
saying generally because we don't know
the exact
details of it
this would work
so if we flipped the the positions of
the parties and Mr Sanderson was in
front Miss Paltrow came from behind
using this uh as a good visual for the
jury we explain that your opinions about
what we would expect to happen
on Mr Ramon's account I should say Well
Mr Ramon's account is very different
because in Mr Ramon's account Mr
Sanderson goes spread eagle and his skis
go out into that V and the inside edges
catch and that changes the kinematics
the motion it's a very different version
of what happens with the contact
and
in terms
I I guess we've covered that so maybe
we'll wrap up here the
um
you've covered a lot of things a lot of
new things perhaps for members of the
jury and those of us in the room will
you um
will you
summarize for us
um what is what are the main points you
want to get across for the jury here
sure the first is that Dr babe cannot
say with any accuracy that Miss Paltrow
landed on Mr Sanderson his calculations
are wrong and when you look at the
equations done properly
Mr Sanderson can land on the snow and
sustain his injuries without Miss
Paltrow falling on him and if I may not
for sure was it your understanding that
Dr Babe's opinion was that his account
was the only possible way the injuries
could occur yes Mr Ramon's version was
the only possible way he said Miss
paltrows was impossible which I believe
is false I think Miss Paltrow's version
is possible
right and would you say that miss
pouchos is the more likely of the two
accounts well considering it's the only
one that matches with the physics of
what would happen in contact yes I think
so okay and I interrupted you you were
going through your main points what was
the next one I think we've covered it
the second thing is that Dr bam cannot
say that Miss Paltrow's version is
impossible that's absolutely wrong it
sounds like you're saying in contrast to
Dr Bain that there are various ways this
uh accident could have happened the
injuries could have
occurred for Mr Sanderson is that right
that's correct and
um you've evaluated the various
testimony correct
you've done a careful analysis from a
biomechanical engineer's perspective on
what different scenarios might be likely
or how they would happen correct correct
and and is it your opinion that Miss
paucho's version is the more likely of
the two versions that you looked at Mr
Ramones and Miss Paltrow yes once again
it's the only version out of the two
that matches with the laws of physics
the the biomechanics of it okay
anything else you'd like to tell the
jury that maybe I I interrupted you on
and you you missed out on
I think we're we're good okay thank you
that's all for now your honor
screen there sure you can turn it off
well actually leave it on for right now
on or off okay
do you prefer doctor sure sure that
works sure doctor sure
um
this version right here
you back it up about to here on the
scroll
to here yeah and then go forward it out
halfway between the last one
a little farther
just before when we when uh
Mr Sanderson who's also uh maybe it's
easier if you did well could you just go
a little bit farther forward just go
slow I just want to get Mr Sanderson who
sometimes called Dr Sanderson
that allows you to be picked up
okay okay go a little farther forward
please
and then when we get okay now this is uh
Terry Sanderson that's Mr Sanderson
that's right okay
so his right eye is
okay go a little farther
down
you know fractions
so
you have a you have his head turned
that's based on your testimony that uh
he is looking
down the hill I guess is that what
you're saying uh I believe his testimony
is that he's looking at a woman who's a
little downhill to the left
he notices her looks at her I don't
remember what the exact words are okay
go a little farther
so his head his
his left eye would be looking directed
Miss Paltrow he was he was right
I believe so he and uh it's inconsistent
with his testimony he didn't see her at
all that's correct
wouldn't he I would think so
farther just another fraction
okay
now in this picture you don't have
doctor or excuse me Craig Ramon in there
who
how far above
would
point be
where I just pointed 20 yards without
the above
image right here I I don't know without
doing a measurement but I'm
concentrating on the collision between
Mr Sanderson and Miss Paltrow
well Craig Ramon testifies he was about
30 to 40 feet above
so these objects are about five you know
been over maybe five feet high
so we just
six bodies we'd get to 30 feet
that would be about right here
I'm not sure
well you're an engineer highly trained
PhD you can't even guesstimate that uh
that would be about 30 feet
I I can't tell what uh up here be 30
feet
don't you think it'd be a lot more than
30 feet
probably but I don't know
will you helped create this animation
you don't know the distances in your own
animation
you know I've concentrated on the
Collision portion that's the
biomechanics portion
okay who did the uh as the estimates or
guesstimates of the distances of their
bodies of the other people so that's
going to be uh Mr boggard who's going to
be on soon I assume
Okay so
uh this animation doesn't have Craig
Ramon in in the scene at all not at this
point
okay
is it because the defense doesn't want
him in the scene
so to discredit his witness account
oh I don't think that's the case at all
and you'll have to ask Mr Bogart
okay we will
okay let's see just go another little
section
you just tell me when I'll keep going
yeah just go slow I just want to go slow
motion
okay now stop right there
now do you know the top how much time
from the initial let's say impact of
their bodies to this point would be you
did this calculation this is your your
bail awake you're what you're talking
about
do you mean in the animation or do you
mean in real I know
Yeah Yeah from the impact at this point
approximately
fourth of a second a half a second tenth
of a second do you miss Paltrow says
that they're in contact for a little
while a few seconds before they fall
over so
um I I don't know what it is
in particular in this animation
if that's what you're asking so you
helped design this part of the animation
so you don't know how far
it is you just guessed it again we don't
know exact timing and distance this
represents an illustration of the
version so
um
yeah it is what it is it's an
illustrator an illustration of the
version but there could be wide
variability in that version right there
is variability but we have constraints
on it
the constraints are it could have
happened the opposite way right
the opposite way no Miss Paltrow hit
Terry Sanderson no I don't think so not
with the testimony that's given we have
two versions We have Mr Ramon's version
and we have missed Miss Paltrow's
version this is Miss Paltrow's version
Mr Ramon's version is very different
okay let's talk about that for a second
um
line
you're being paid excuse me you're being
paid
what is it 425 an hour for this no is it
more than 425 an hour it is
um 450 an hour 500 it's 500 an hour 500
an hour
and uh you build something over ten
thousand dollars so far for your work
that sounds about right
more than fifteen thousand no I don't
think so so between ten and fifteen
thousand
okay
um you can turn that off for right now
what's the best way to do it is
disconnected
okay
no you're here to teach the uh the jury
right the defendants version correct uh
teach the jury the physics that would be
helpful in understanding how to assess
the accident
so that's a no you're not teaching the
defendant's version
I'm not teaching any version I'm
teaching the physics and mechanical
engineering biomechanical engineering
that would help the jury I know it's
hard for expert witnesses to say yes or
no but
are you teaching the defendant's version
I guess I don't understand the question
okay
seemed like a simple question
next I'd like to uh
talk about did you review Dr Gibby's
testimony at trial uh no but I did see
some of his trial testimony
all of it are some of it some of it
was it more than 10 minutes
probably yeah
more than 20 minutes
yep
more than an hour I don't think more
than an hour okay
you didn't disclose anything about
hearing Dr Gibby's testimony
um
through what you mean but I did see it
okay
um
you've never disclosed to the plaintiff
your reports or your testimony ahead of
this trial correct all right
um may we approach
yes
foreign
are you an expert on broken ribs
I am comfortable talking about the
biomechanics related to rib fractures
have you done any papers or studies or
research on
ribs and rib fractures me personally no
but I've read the biomechanical and
Engineering literature relevant to them
um you haven't mentioned that
biomechanical literature
specifics correct
I'm not sure about in specifics but I
think we mentioned it on direct
okay
so you said that uh
Dr Sanderson I'm just going to call him
Terry Terry was 70 years old at the time
of this crash it was 69 but
effectively 70 for biomechanics purposes
effectively because 70 years older
no because there's actually good
information in the biomechanical
engineering literature about the amount
of chest compression required to create
rib fractures for 70 year olds
and not 69 year olds well it's actually
the full distribution but the paper that
I'm thinking of from Agnew specifically
talks about 70 year olds
you didn't mention that paper today no
but you would you like it not right now
thanks
I've not seen it
um
I'm going to go right to the another
point
you have this theory of rotation correct
that your the version you're calling
Miss Paltrow's version is a kind of a
rotation version
there is some rotation it may be a
little it might be more than a little we
don't know
okay so we don't know how much rotation
there is
correct sure okay
I'd like to
let me see what this thing is it did
work last time
I guess it's working now
may we take a picture of this I think
you've already done it for someone on
your team ask okay good
you may borrow a pen
your honor we would object to him
writing on the witnesses board
it's not an exhibit he's it's certainly
fair game okay
so well Dr can we mark it as an exhibit
your honor why don't you take a picture
of it and you can use that and then he
can you can add to it okay
it is our board
right in in academics we don't we don't
have any questions right now so in
academic Fields it's common that people
write on each other's uh drawings
correct
I don't know that I've seen that but I
don't have a problem with you drawing
okay
so um
you testified that Craig Ramon says
Terry was hit directly in the back
and they went down and Craig Ramon was
somewhere above 30 to 40 feet
and it happened in a fraction of a
second correct
yes the fall I would agree with that
okay less than a second
sure okay
so uh there was a screen
so with and the screen occurred and
there was within a fraction of a second
and uh
I don't believe uh Craig Ramon never
testified where Miss Paltrow's skis were
correct so her skis could have been
going underneath Terry
like this
so the pink ones are would be Miss
Paltrow skis
is that a version that is possible it is
none
it's a
uh
you're saying it's not possible that is
not possible with the version that Mr
Ramon States
his version
didn't talk about her skis now here I'll
draw what her body let's pink would be
her body still Square in the back
isn't that possible
so no with Mr Ramon's version if I may
um that is not possible so in this
situation here when Mr sanderson's skis
go into a V and I guess you're saying
her skis are under his skis which I'm
not sure how that happens because the
tips curve up but we'll go with it
somehow
she winds up in this situation getting
caught with her left ski around Mr
Sanderson and she would not continue
past five to ten feet and I would expect
a twisting release of her left ski well
that's her version I'm talking about Mr
Ramon's version no no I'm talking about
what you just drew for Mr Ramon's
version Mr Ramon's well isn't it
possible her skis could be pointing
straight like this
and uh let me get it right here
so
yeah so
she could be going straight and she
could be turning left
and up
and hit Square in the back but and her
skis are pointed this way isn't that
another version
so for her skis to miss oh no it's not
do you want me to explain
half a second
I'm asking the questions here so
the uh
so are you saying that her body could
not be turned well her skis are going in
one direction or she's turning up to the
left is that is that possible not for Mr
Ramon's version is it possible in
general sure but in her version I'm
sorry in his version this happened in a
fraction of a second
I don't think Mr Ramon testified that he
has a videographic or photographic
memory
do you
well he's pretty particular in his
testimony about how she was on Mr
sanderson's back
right and he could
you see the circle I have
let's see well actually um
maybe I could do it I got it wrong
let's do it the other way
her
her body to be like this
and her skis could be like this too
in
people turn all the time while they're
skiing and their skis are going One
Direction but their body is pointing to
different but here
can you see me
you see that I see you turning sure
that's possible Right
what you're doing in general is possible
are you asking does that match with Mr
Ramon's testimony no and I'm happy to
explain why I think Mr Ramon's testimony
is
uh it happens at a fraction of a second
Mr Ramon
professional wannabe freestyle skier
likes to talk about ski angles but the
main part is the body he saw the body
and then the bodies go down together and
she lands on top of him
saying that your versions which you are
not based on anything
except
uh
your Recreation of the biomechanics are
superior to an eyewitness is that what
you're saying no we have two versions of
the accident we have Mr Ramon's version
and we have Miss Paltrow's version I
have assessed both using physics and
biomechanics and I'm sorry to say Mr
Ramon's version does not meet with the
laws of physics it's not consistent
internally consistent and Miss paltrows
is
well I don't think Mr Ramone's version
was designed to be consistent with the
version of events it happened in less
than a second and we don't know the
direction of the skis
in his version he never testified to the
direction of his Paltrow's skis in any
of his testimony isn't that true
he did not testify to the direction of
our schemes that's true thank you so if
Miss Paltrow
was seen Down
turning up to the left
she hits the Terry Sanderson Square in
the back
and they go they can fall down to the
right
especially if her momentum
is going well you know I'm not a
biomechanical engineer I'll try to do it
right here
it could be her shoulder it had some
Square in the back
he didn't say what a part of this
palpro's body
Mr Sanderson did he he did not say he
said well here I can tell you what
exactly what he said he said
he said squarely in the back she
couldn't have hit him in the back any
better right in the middle than if she
tried and she couldn't have been back on
his back anymore than if he would have
strapped her on the back like a backpack
okay but that doesn't mean her body was
straight
might not be exactly straight
yeah it could be off center because she
was
skiing down she's like this and she hits
him right in the back
or maybe it was a little off center
because Mr Center because Mr Ramon only
had the view for a few seconds
and then
her arms wrap around
her arms could have wrapped around Terry
Sanderson right
I don't think there's any testimony
about that is it possible maybe but well
where would they have gone
down to the side is he went in like this
um
in front of her
um I mean the most likely don't ski or
ski like this usually
often often what are the other positions
if you have her arms in more okay let's
have them out more so she could be like
this down like this and the poles
heading back okay there's all sorts of
options
so in that fraction of a second Mr Ramon
saw the Collision the screen was up here
he turns his head
and she could hit him squaring the back
she could have her at that point her
body could have turned and possibly hit
her but the point is the skis could have
been going at a different angle
one or the other
and still caused this crash and your
versions assume those are not possible
because
you assume that
that there's only one way that their
skis were going parallel to each other
this is the this is your only assumption
right wrong
you assume you've made assumptions that
these are possible I looked at other
angles that's right
and the testimony though
you said uh
there's no testimony about the angle of
her skis from Mr Ramon correct that's
true
you've made a lot of assumptions correct
to make these animations right
um
yes and no
I thought that would be a
more than one assumption
there are some assumptions
sure more than one assumption okay
less than a hundred
sure
less than 10.
I don't know you don't know how many
assumptions you've made correct
that's right sure okay
I know Council
Mr Owens likes to do this a lot like
it's a touchdown
but
on redirect Mr Ramon did you see all of
his testimony this for this trial
I don't know if I saw all of it but
certainly I saw a lot of it
okay you saw the testimony last week
correct
is there any more than that there was a
little bit yesterday okay I didn't see
anything yesterday traveling had to do
with that he reported Mr Ramon reported
what he he saw
the same day in the same week seven
years ago
and you're recreating this what about
five months ago correct
I don't remember when it was less than a
year ago
you don't recall when you made your
consulted with Mr Brill and made the
animation this has been ongoing for a
while this case has been dragging on so
I don't know when it was
so you've been working on this for let's
say more than eight months
sure you don't know
um certainly we've been in contact with
the council for longer than eight months
but for the record your honor I'd like
to move to strike all of his testimony
because
this wasn't disclosed improperly
I I anticipate the rules I just wanted
for the record make them it's overruled
it was disclosed properly Council okay
what I'd like to do is uh
understand that you've made a lot of
assumptions and the jury would like to
know how reliable your opinions are so
how can that be reliable when you
totally discount some major events like
what the direction of Miss Paltrow's
body was compared to her skis and there
is testimony about
Miss Paltrow's
body movement
um
do you know that
just prior to the crash what version are
you talking about I don't know what
you're talking about sorry do you know
about the version of Carrie Oaks
I don't think she saw the accident
have you read her deposition I have
okay you realize she testified that
one of the kids said Mommy watch us ski
and the kids were up there on the left
Miss Paltrow was down on the right which
would tend to show that
Miss Paltrow was looking up to her left
at the point of collision
I don't recall that
okay
so Yuri
you're excluding Kerry oaks's testimony
correct that's wrong
you're including her testimony I
considered it sure
and you
are there any assumptions you've made
based on her testimony
not in particular that I can think of
but there may be could you speak up not
in particular that I can think of okay
not particularly that you can think of
about carry ox's testimony okay
are you an expert on head injuries
I'm comfortable talking about head
injuries from the biomechanic standpoint
have you ever studied
or held yourself out as an expert on
concussion
if it's diagnosing or treating
concussion no if it's the biomechanics
related to the formation of concussion
yes I've done helmet research and head
injury research in particular for snow
Sports
did you apply any of your knowledge
about concussion to this case
I certainly looked at it but Dr Bain was
very particular in his testimony that it
was only the rib fractures that allowed
him to say that Miss Paltrow contacted
Mr Sanderson from behind so that's what
I concentrated on for the jury
and you ignored his discussion about the
head injury oh no I certainly considered
it
and it's not relevant in this case well
in disproving Dr bam it's not relevant
but I'm happy to talk about it
well it's not clear you disproved Dr
bang when you don't even know the
direction of Miss Paltrow's skis
at the beginning of this it's also
I think a big assumption to say what the
body position of Miss Paltrow was when
she hit
Terry Sanderson in the back
and I don't was there a question in
there Council just if that was accurate
I'll withdraw it
so you've never studied rib injuries
have you ever testified about rib
injuries before
clarify
the question is have you ever studied
rib injuries and
testified about them in the past
two questions have you ever testified
about rib injuries in the past
I I don't recall but it's likely
most likely you have I think so how many
have you testified more than 100 times
in trial probably 35 times something in
that ballpark
in total under oath have you testified
more than a hundred times including
depositions yes
more than less than 200 times I would
agree with that
okay
let me just check
that's all I have for now thank you Dr
sure thank you thank you Mr Bueller Mr
Egan yeah
thank you your honor Dr sure we'll just
be real quick here
did anything Mr Bueller asked you change
your opinion that Miss Paltrow's account
is consistent with the laws of physics
to your understanding and Mr Ramones is
not
That Remains the Same
thanks
Mr Bueller
before you're an expert in the laws of
physics but you're not an expert in
Medical
uh
medicine or Orthopedics
or neurology correct
I am a biomechanical engineer I am not a
medical doctor I do not diagnose and
treat but I do look at what forces and
what motions create damage to the body
you may step down thank you thank you
may call your next Witness
we call Paul bonger your honor thank you
or before Mr Bogger
because I we may want to take a five or
ten minute break I want to dress
something with
with the jury we'll have to take one
shortly anyway so let's go ahead and do
it now
miss van Orman
your honor pursuant to our motion and
limiting Mr bogger's testimony is going
to be significantly Limited in this case
the problem that I am foreseeing is that
um I and I could be wrong but it appears
to me that council is going to try and
use Mr Bogger to then
um describe some further animations and
place individuals on that animation and
I have significant concerns with that
for a number of reasons number one Mr
bogger's not qualified to do that he
didn't take any kind of measurements
calculations determinations of speed
force physics Etc in this case but in
addition in his report he does not make
any mention of where people were where
they were placed this would any kind of
discussion of him talking about the
animation and if he was responsible for
putting the people somehow on that
animation he does not describe that in
his report he doesn't talk that in his
report regarding
participating in an animation he
provides you know diagrams in his report
no discussions of where people were or
weren't so I don't think that it would
be appropriate for him to even deal with
the animation or that his testimony that
he's the one that was responsible for
putting say apple here and Moses here
here and that type of thing that would
go significantly beyond anything he did
in his report
so that's my concern I wanted to address
that now rather than a sidebar
thank you
John Mayer could take a look at this one
sure
Mr Egan
yes you're on Earth so I think our
response would be that
um Mr Bogger has
poured over the records in this case and
he has in producing these animations
made certain assumptions about which
what testimony
might be consistent with the
illustration that the animations provide
he can be very clear with the jury that
he's assuming certain facts he's not
finding these facts he's assuming that
they're true they come from the record
he can explain that they're they're
rough illustrations he's not made
measurements and decided that yes it's
this is exactly 30 feet I mean he can be
subject to cross-examination on
um on any point that might be
inconsistent with testimony he can
explain that he chose to assume these
facts and not other facts and if you
assumed other facts you might get
different illustration
and then uh he you know he'll explain
that the Assumption of various facts
that are shown in the
animations are consistent with
standing of ski collisions and ski
skiing skiing generally which he has
Decades of experience not just with
skiing himself but with investigating
accidents collisions hundreds and
hundreds of them for various purposes
mostly not litigation mostly to figure
out risk management concerns deciding
whether certain skiers have to be banned
from a certain Resort or a ski area
he's he has
ample experience to be able to discuss
how to
consider various factors in a
evaluating a ski Collision like this
that has complex
testimony that's not all consistent and
the jury in our in our view needs to
hear from a ski expert that knows how to
do that and can explain to them the
principles that he uses he will not tell
the jury this is likely what happened or
that I have found that this has this
must be the case he'll say I've assumed
these facts can be very clear about what
he's assumed and then use that animation
to explain to the jury How to Think
Through the case given his ample
experience with evaluating ski
collisions
so Mr Egan I guess I'm still not hearing
an expert opinion for Mr Bogger is it
that uh that would have helped the jury
I mean if your everything that I'm
hearing has him weighing evidence has
him making decisions about what may have
happened on that day and that's invading
the Providence of the jury it's not
really going to help them
your honor I see it as uh like say in
medical malpractice case which I'm more
familiar with if a certain set of facts
might be in the record about what
happened in a surgery for example then a
surgeon expert surgeon who has lots of
experience reviewing and Records but
also doing the surgery himself knowing
what the training is
looks at the records looks at the
various claims and and you as you said
in your order ruling I believe yesterday
can say I if we assume these facts given
my expertise I can say this makes sense
or this is consistent with my
understanding of surgery
and so my
um my proposal is that we use Mr bocker
in that sort of way where he can help
the jury understand given what he knows
about skiing and given he's seen in the
record that there are certain
principles you can use if you assume
certain facts to
um
to evaluate a certain Collision such
that you you're applying some rational
principles rather than just generally
going with a certain Gestalt feeling
about what someone said you're actually
trying to rationally go through how to
evaluate a ski Collision which again he
has decades and Decades of experience
doing and he won't say he'll say to the
jury you're the ones that have to decide
what happened this is a very difficult
case to decide
your medical malpractice expert example
isn't that an expert that's coming in to
evaluate
whether the standard of care was
breached
yeah well so I yes usually we would we
would offer an expert in that way but
given your ruling I'm just trying to use
that as an analogy where we could still
use expertise that would help the jury
without rendering that that final
opinion telling them
you know as an expert I you know you
should you should do this and I'm really
the one that knows because I have tons
of experience instead he can say here's
here's how I evaluate these accidents
and let me show you how to do it and
then they have they have rational
principles that come from his field of
skiing and ski accident evaluation that
that help them that they have not heard
they haven't heard from any ski expert
that has provided to them that kind of a
rational
layout for analyzing the various complex
claims in this case and I think that
would help them sure and I think I in my
I guess preliminary ruling on this
Witness
the other day yesterday
I'm losing track of the days here I
think I stated that he is qualified
certainly has qualifications and can
testify as to what a reasonable skier
would do or not do in a certain
hypothetical set of facts but in terms
of applying and weighing the evidence in
this case I think that goes too far
okay so but but if if we showed the
animation and we made it clear that the
jury that we're assuming certain facts
were not we're not weighing them we're
just saying look let's let's take these
facts we're assuming them we're not
saying that they're proven we're just
showing you how to analyze the facts
assuming these uh these various parts of
the testimony are true that would be too
far you're saying that sounds like
closing argument
it doesn't sound like what a witness can
offer under rule 702
talk about I mean he's an expert in
skiing he can talk about skiing Dynamics
he can explain what a snowplow is what
parallel skiing is what uh what the
rules of of skiing are generally
understood to be but in terms of taking
that next leap
I don't I don't think he can he can say
I've looked at the deposition testimony
and I can tell you who's at fault here
or I can tell you who did something
wrong here
I just don't see I think that's the
jury's responsibility and I don't want a
witness telling the jury how to make its
decisions or how to think how to how to
make a decision that's either an
ultimate issue or one of the issues
leading up to that ultimate issue
so even him explaining his process for
how to evaluate ski collisions would be
too far
to what end
what is the jury need to know how he
evaluates a ski Collision
because evaluating ski collisions is a
complex matter and he has expertise as
to how to do that yeah you know right
now I'm just talking in a or I'm
responding to your question sort of in a
vacuum I don't know what it is he's
offering
um if it would help I could give you
kind of an example like sure if I could
say you Mr Bogger when you evaluate ski
collisions and you've evaluated they
have established that he's evaluated
hundreds of and hundreds of ski
collisions
um have you ever evaluated collisions
where there's conflicting testimony yes
when you approach that testimony what
are principles you use to evaluate that
and he can explain those principles he
doesn't have to talk about the facts of
this case he can explain here are these
principles I don't think the juries
heard that I think it would be helpful
to them I think it would be rational and
not over it wouldn't be overbearing
asking him how he evaluates
credibility
um
I guess that's true how does he
reconcile different accounts right but
we wouldn't if I mean if given your
ruling we we wouldn't go into applying
it to this case we would just give them
the rational principles that would help
them uh weigh the evidence it wouldn't
tell them how to do it it would just
give them a framework for doing it which
only he can provide they have not heard
from somebody that has that does this
for a living has done it again how does
that vary from what the jury does
if you look at the credibility and jury
instruction that I've already read for
example and how does that differ mean
where it talks about conflicting
testimony how does it how does what he's
offering provide any specialized
knowledge I consider that generalization
yeah so I don't think he would just talk
about you know
um general principles of evaluating
Witnesses he would talk about particular
aspects of a ski ski slope or Witnesses
on us
um
if you were here right now you could
help me
um
yeah right he is right here so when when
ski accidents happen uh
and people go to the ground their their
skis get released
I could see that as specialized
knowledge just like this witness offered
something along those lines no that
isn't that that is an important thing he
can but in terms of
this skier said such and such and this
gear said such and such but this is what
I this is how I evaluate that aspect of
it I think that's invading the
Providence of the jury
okay on deciding how to weigh testimony
okay I mean for the record if if I may
your honor would just I think we put
this on before but in case we didn't we
we believe the motion uh to exclude Dr
Bogger or limit his testimony is
untimely and that um Greg scored us
their expert who whose report does much
the same thing that Mr boggers report
does should be limited in the same way
um
and uh again just renew our requests
that he'll be able to speak to the jury
about his evaluation the ski accident
so just again Mike my sort of ultimate
conclusion on what I'm hearing from on
this motion to reconsider and on the
response from the defense is that it's
up to the jury to decide ultimately what
the parties did
where the parties were positioned and
who ran into whom
so it's up for the jury to make those
decisions so as long as this witness
tears clear of those areas that's the
main emphasis of my of my preliminary
ruling and I'll have to hear what is
what's being offered do you mind uh I
know I'm not an old man but my memory
has failed me this three again who hit
whom going backwards Missouri to decide
ultimately what the parties did right in
other words leading up to during and
after the accident it's up for the jury
to decide that
um where the and various experts have
given them
some helpful information like the uh the
the biomedical expert gave testimony as
to what the biomedical evidence
reflected that would help the jury make
that decision just like this past
witness gave the jury some uh
biomechanical information that will help
the jury make their decision about what
happened in that accident what the
parties did where the parties were
positioned and who ran into whom
and and the reason that you see Mr
Burger as doing something different than
like say doctor sure just did who took
the jury through a assuming these
various facts I'm not telling you that
this account is true
and I'm just taking their the as an
assumption what Ms Paltrow said was true
let's analyze it you're seeing Mr bonger
as different and I'm not totally sure
how do you mind explaining that
plaintiff's witness
applied biomedical principles in a
methodical way to the different versions
and then handed the jury that
information the biomechanical expert
that just testified
applied biomechanical principles to the
different versions and gave that
information to the jury to help them
make a decision okay so and what I what
I see this witness doing is reading
different accounts and reconciling them
and wanting to give that his his
reconciliation to the jury which I think
is too close to what the jury actually
does it doesn't provide any
it doesn't help the jury from an expert
standpoint okay so it sounds like you're
not persuaded that you know of our
position which is that he has skiing
expertise similar to like a
biomechanical engineer has and can apply
that to the facts in a way that would
provide the jury with some again
rational
scheme to assess the the uh accident
that they wouldn't have otherwise under
rule 702
and and the same would like is likely
going to hold true to Mr scordus's
testimony
I haven't I mean I've heard I've heard
you make kind of emotion I haven't heard
from the other side whether they're
opposing that in some way you just
waiting until you have questions I mean
if he's the same type of an expert and I
I realize that he may not be a risk
manager and he may not uh
be a a ski accident investigator for for
an employer but it sounds like his
testimony is along the same lines
so
um just in terms of guidance on this
ruling
um
you you mentioned the findings and I
apologize for going along I just want to
make sure that we
um
specialized knowledge right so it can
help the jury in making their decisions
so what in your mind would something
like recognizing that the positioning of
the skiers if one skier is uphill
applying a certain knowledge of skiing
um uh that that would suggest certain
things about the accident would that be
out of bounds
I guess I have to hear the question but
it it sounds like you're
getting back into the you know making
conclusions based on an investigation if
you say if you if you lay out some
hypothetical facts to say if this skier
was here and this skier was here from a
skiing standpoint
you know and then ask questions based on
that I could see that but okay
um
it's feeling a little too hypothetical
right now sure okay thank you your honor
thanks for your patience with my
questions sure miss van Orman
back to why I raised this in the first
place is the concern with the animation
and so what I don't want because Mr
Bogger apparently had some involvement
in in creating the animation which was
not designated in his report nor was any
mention on what his involvement was what
he did for it how he placed anybody
anybody anywhere there's no discussion
of any of that I don't think that it's
appropriate for him to comment on the
animation and to say well yes I I saw
that you know this helps me because I'm
the one who helped to place these people
there it would have been Again by
reading the depositions and applying
which is what the jury needs to do so I
would say he can't even talk about the
animations because that just goes beyond
the scope of his report anything that
he's done in the case
I would agree
unless the foundation can be set I mean
I haven't heard anything that would
establish a foundation
broadsided your honor we had a 37-page
report produced a long long time ago
there was a motion deadline that we
respected
months ago
that these issues were ordered were
argued 45 days ago
and then immediately before our witness
is going to take the stand with this
37-page report
we get
essentially a midnight filing
and that got half of his opinions I
don't think it's fair your honor I can't
even read the darn thing I'm focused on
getting my Witnesses ready
the untimeliness is very prejudicial to
us your honor because we can't properly
brief this in days
I've already ruled that the that the
initial motion was timely and and I made
a ruling on the initial motion the
subsequent motion was not untimely the
court has agreed to reconsider the
motion and that's what I've done and I
don't feel that it's unfair or unduly
prejudicial you are aware of the issues
with his report long ago but but you
ruled in our favor before what I Ruled
was that the that the initial motion
didn't give the court enough to Grant it
because they
and so that they were the most briefed
it then there was a motion to reconsider
that gave the court more information and
I can see that it would be
I mean you can't poorly breathe this
would create an appealable issue do you
want to do that for your client is my
question
no but I don't I don't wanna
they poorly brief something the judge
denies it
then right before the testimony they
better brief it and now we lose I mean
that's what trial is this is trial
things happen
um the the points that were raised in
the motion are valid points they're
sound they're based soundly on the law
and I and I want to make sure that what
the jury hears
is sound and and not subject to any more
risk of appeal than possible
we'll take five before the jury comes
back
um
ready for the jury
yes
yes okay
I didn't hear anything so they went to
get the jury
I see that
thank you
Mr Owen you may proceed
James again okay Mr Egan we call Paul
Bogger our ski expert thank you Mr
Bogger
if you could walk right over here to the
clerk and she will swear you in as a
witness
do you swear that the testimony you are
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
God thank you
good morning
start by sitting down and then giving
the jury your full name and spelling it
to get situated thank you very much
yes my name is Paul Bogger
p-a-u-l-b-a-u-g-h-e-r
unner I note that my computer is still
there do you mind if I grab it sure
Mr Bogger thank you for being with us
um thank you
will you tell the jury what you
understand To Be Your Role here today
yes I was retained to do an
investigation to consider all the
circumstances involved in the accident
that you've been sitting through here
and I've also been asked to
if asked to assume certain facts I could
Give opinions as to how that might work
with every plausible do I see this I
think maybe a lot of what I would hope
to add today would be to
sort of give the operational side the
skiing side the things that we observe
and accidents and when we evaluate them
what we learn and what I pass on I do a
lot of teaching and training which we
can get into but those are I think the
sort of the key the key areas so do you
have expertise to
help educate the jury about the skier
responsibility code yes or just
reasonable principles about how to ski
yes
um what about how
like for example
um bindings uh and ski equipment might
factor into how they might work in a
certain Collision
yes
and why do you why do you have uh
confidence that you can explain that and
with authority to the jury
well I've been involved in working
professionally in the ski industry for
37 years and I've primarily focused on
the outdoor on snow
skiing more specifically ski safety that
involves ski accidents I do a lot of ski
accident investigation I mean literally
thousands and thousands and I've done a
lot of collisions I've worked on a lot
of collisions and I haven't just done it
at one ski area in my home ski area but
I've I actually had four ski areas that
I did uh risk management oversight for
and and I'm primarily a patrol director
at my base but then I moved into more
supervisory roles that started to
involve other ski areas as well
including one in Canada one here in Utah
that you're probably familiar with
Brighton
and uh
those experiences of looking at these
accidents in a variety of locations has
given me quite a bit of information I
can use to a
do the day-to-day use of that do we need
to address certain issues on the hill do
we need to remove a skier for example if
somebody's unsafe in bad collisions and
bad accidents we really do need to learn
as much as we can we get medical
feedback we get we just consider a lot
of information and then the last piece
of that is I pass a lot of that on I've
been training and teaching
people in the ski industry about
accident investigations skier collisions
gear safety uh for the last 20 years and
so I've been all over on that do you
have any higher education yes I have a
degree in economics
and what about
um
certifications that are related to Ski
Sports or skiing
yes I would have a number of
certifications I'm not sure how many of
them would bear directly on the ski
accident part but uh you know I'm an EMT
an instructor of outdoor emergency care
a licensed Blaster an aerial Blaster
which means we can use explosives from
helicopters and and mostly for Avalanche
control well I guess only for Avalanche
control if there's anything else
probably probably be a big problem
I'm sure my license doesn't say that but
uh and then I have a number of uh
schools that have attended Avalanche
schools and various ski risk management
type things and then you know as I said
really the last 20 25 years of my career
I've been mostly teaching and training
others whether it's a
the national Avalanche school which we
actually just held here in Utah in the
fall or
Consulting for ski areas working with
the national ski areas Association on
national Safety campaigns the national
ski patrol system was on the national
Safety Board and so there's a lot of
related things but I mean I think that's
the gist that you know I've been
involved in
you know I like to even say as you know
I've been referred to as an expert in
this for a long time and I've done a lot
of Trials and testimony on ski cases but
I always think of myself too as a
student I'm all I'm continually learning
about it I always want to know the next
thing and you think they're all the same
and a lot are fairly similar but there's
always something new and something
different so
have you ever in your
um
capacity you mentioned of
reviewing cases for litigation or giving
testimony in court cases have you ever
done that in Utah before yes yes I had a
yeah well I've had a number of uh secure
collisions that I've investigated here
now with Brighton that's more my
oversight and I'm reviewing the accident
records and then when we have a bigger
Collision that has more issues and so
forth or a ski accident for that matter
you know I'll get involved and I you
know start going through a review like
much like we've been doing here and I
had a trial I think three or four years
ago in Salt Lake uh Solitude the ski
area was involved and um
uh Park City I've had a couple of
collisions at Park City that I've done
expert reports and and so forth but uh
you know those cases settled but but
anyway so yeah and that's again I think
what's different about what I do than
say maybe what Mr Graf would have been
doing it when he was the patrol manager
is that I I do travel and I do go to all
the different
parts of the country including the East
Coast for accidents and the
investigations and skier collisions
happen basically everywhere and that's
been a
I'd say I've probably had 20 uh
cases that have gone to trial that I've
been involved in maybe they haven't all
gone to trial but at least that have
been in litigation
and are you aware of any studies or have
you done any measurements of how common
ski accidents might be
well I'm certainly uh I work with people
who who actually are involved in the uh
what we call the 10-year interval
studies and there's been four tenure
interval studies about ski accidents and
the mechanisms of ski accidents I look
at that data I also uh excuse me I think
you heard Dr share earlier describing
the ISS
s uh the the snow Sports and Trauma uh
you know the international Congress for
ski safety on that and I've presented
there I've presented a
I you know I can't probably keep track
of all the different meetings and and
groups that I've presented to but these
are bigger groups the ISS and then I've
you know I also present papers and and
do peer-reviewed uh uh work the
international snow science conference
issw Workshop has a
that was dreamed up in the 80s they
haven't lost that part of it but it's a
conference it's an International
Conference a thousand people there I do
reports on things that happen ski area
problem ski
in fact one ski problem with the snow
immersion suffocation
I don't know if you've heard of that you
might have heard of tree will fatalities
did you remember we just had one
here in in Utah and and so that would be
something I would gather data on I
talked to the general manager of the ski
area that it happened adjacent to and
and talked to the folks from the
Avalanche Center here forecast Center
and they have some educational Outreach
that they do and I basically was at the
uh
front of the snow version piece I helped
coin that term and and we did it you
know I keep a database I keep doing
ongoing research I see you have another
question coming no no it's fine well I
just don't mind me interrupting so the
the when it comes to measuring that how
common a ski collisions might be on uh
in a given region or in a given place at
a given time do you have any particular
data you can offer yeah well certainly
um if you looked at I mentioned those
interval studies uh the rate in skiing
accidents the total skiing accidents of
collisions is about six to seven percent
of all of the reported accidents now I'm
sure there's a lot of collisions where
people just bump into each other and go
on their way probably a lot more of
those but uh ones that result
if this is just
around the foundation on Mr bogger's
experience but this goes beyond anything
contained in his report
you see it as backgrounds are overruled
yeah
so um that rate at six to seven percent
is sort of uncanny from interval to
interval so 40 Years of data now and
it's still the same and now I use that
metric myself because I'm looking at the
four ski areas that I'm supervising and
then the other ski areas that I go to
when I do investigations I look at their
data because the first thing I want to
know is what is that rate here and it
can vary throughout the season based on
weather conditions and smoke surfaces
and so forth but you know that's a
metric is are we doing okay do we have a
problem is there something that needs to
be addressed and so I look at it in all
accidents there's all kinds of data you
can get from accidents not just gear
collisions in that way and then we try
to pass that information on sometimes we
target it towards
safety Outreach what you can look at a
lot of safety stuff on the national ski
areas association website that anybody
can log on to and look at the safety
pages and a lot of stuff on collisions
that's in there and skiing safely and so
forth I had a lot to offer in the in the
production of all that thank you
um do you have any knowledge of how what
the rate of uh ski collisions might be
in Utah
yes and it would be almost identical
yeah there might be again minor
variations from ski area to ski area but
if you looked at Deer Valley for example
which I did and I asked this question
during my site inspection and the rate
is just right in there it's probably six
percent seven percent how many
collisions and I'm talking not ski
accidents but collisions where two
skiers are hitting against each other uh
how many uh collisions like that have
you investigated evaluated in your
career yeah I looked through uh sort of
back through the accident review data
that I keep and to just look at what you
saw the other day the incident report
form and maybe it's got something like
an additional patroller comment or a ski
instructor's incident report
I looked through that and I figured
there have been about four thousand of
those that I reviewed out of about 44
000 accidents with just the incident
report form that I've looked at that's
all accidents but collisions
about four thousand and then things that
really got more investigated where
there's things like we're doing here
um 550 is so that's a it's a lot of
accidents and a lot of collisions in
those collisions over a long period of
time sorry sorry I just wanted to make
yes and nobody will think skiing is safe
anymore right yeah so
um
when you've done
um those evaluations uh what is your
role what are you trying to accomplish
as you evaluate those accidents well
sometimes we need to find
the cause mostly we want to know the
cause and certainly that's how you can
Target prevention but we also want to
learn circumstances sometimes we have
really bad injuries in these collisions
and it's important for us to make sure
we know is there somebody at fault or
people meeting the responsibilities and
so we're looking at that all the time
and part of that is we want to make sure
since we're all responsible as skiers
that includes the ski areas me you if
you're skiers that we share safety we
all do it together and we all have
responsibilities and if one of us is not
doing our job people get hurt and so
we need to evaluate
fault at times and it we may address
some people that we actually removed
from the mountain we've had people go
in cop cars off of the mountain but you
know we're serious about it we want our
skiers to know that we're serious about
it they feel okay bringing their kids
there that we're not just turning a
blind eye
so in your evaluation of these various
collisions what have you learned about
what the inherent risks of skiing are
well certainly
skiers
face a variety of inherent risks and
those are often codified into especially
in states that have a lot of skiing in
them like Utah or Washington State or
California you know there's there's what
they call like a ski safety Statute in
uh in the regs and so it will mention
many times it'll enumerate what some of
those inherent risks are another place
you can find those inherent risks or on
trail signs are mandatory here in Utah
and that they're publicly displayed but
also the ticket back sometimes that
varies from place to place but
um do you want me to list any of the
inherent risks sure yeah just to educate
the jury given your experience
investigating these various collisions
and just your experience as this as a
long time Advanced skier what are those
inherent risks objection your honor
relevance
overruled
thank you uh yes so
things that you encounter as a skier
things that you could likely have a
problem with if you weren't paying
attention and weren't following uh your
your role your duties
of uh
things that we would identify under
things like this gear responsibility
code which we can talk about but but
train changes Forest growth bare spots
things that you might run into objects
lift Towers
grooming machines snowmobiles we try to
keep those off the hill when people are
around but you know that's part of the
sport people need to get lift
maintenance people need to get around
the mountain so so what about it would
be in there I'm sorry yes I was just
going to say what about inherent risks
relating to ski collisions and that's
where I was coming so I wanted to give
you the broad brush and then say end
things like inbounds Avalanches you can
actually get even if they do the
mitigation you can actually get uh
into an avalanche in bounds and that's a
risk you hadn't seen identified for a
while but about five or six years ago we
started adding that one and collisions
gear collisions or even collisions with
lift towers and objects but skier
collisions as we know six to seven
percent of the accidents
we can eliminate some things but at
inherent risk you cannot and the
definition there is the risk is inherent
in the sport you cannot remove it
without fundamentally altering the sport
as it exists today so that means using
good
following our good responsibilities and
being prudent skiers we can reduce the
risk but we can't eliminate it
so does that mean that sometimes
collisions occur despite people
reasonably skiing on both sides of an
accident
yes that happens all the time and when
you investigate collisions do you
sometimes after a thorough review
conclude that you can't determine who
was at fault
yes that's common
so just to put that in another way
in your evaluations so will you come to
the conclusion that a certain accident
is in the evidence that you receive in
gathering information about it is uh
not clear enough for you to identify who
is responsible for it yes
let's talk about the skier
responsibility code you mentioned that
yes and it's been brought up before but
since you're the ski expert
let's have you teach us about it for a
second
I believe it is defense
second sorry
thought I had it right here yep it's
defense 91.
any objection to that being published or
I guess I should talk to the judge
91 is received
okay so let's put this up on the screen
it's also on your screen right there Mr
Bogger I think you guys yet and
turn it here so it's a little easier to
see okay so is this the skier
responsibility code you were referencing
earlier it is and it's actually changed
in the last
a few years but but that's the one that
was in existence at the time of this
accident okay got it 2016. 26 February
2016 February that's correct okay and
how do you know about this skier
responsibility code
well it's excuse me it's key to all of
the duties that we were just talking
about in order for people to skiers
for us to do our part and it's a
national code started back in the 60s
with the national ski patrol system
before they had professional ski patrols
at ski areas and
it's used all over
North America Canada has something
called the Alpine responsibility code
it's very similar it has a few more
details on it I've testified in trials
in Australia talking about a code that
they have again very similar to this but
these are basic rules of the road you
have to give people so you can put some
order into the chaos that is skiing you
know skiing is very dynamic as you know
if you're a skier and so you're trying
to put some basic rules in that people
who follow their common sense and oh go
ahead do you know are there ways that
skiers can become familiar with this
responsibility code
yes this is uh published at all skier is
it's on trail maps typically and you'll
find them on big Trails signboards too
at the ski area websites will have it
there's all sorts of places you can go
to find this but it's it's everywhere
okay and
um let's talk about the particular
points here I'll pull them out
maybe like should we just go through
them one by one is that okay sure
however you want it okay so the first
one always stay in control and be able
to stop or avoid other people or objects
that seems fairly Common Sense yes
that's that's if that one doesn't work
the rest of them aren't going to work
and then the second one maybe uh is more
important people ahead of you have the
right of way it is your responsibility
to avoid them can you explain what that
means for skiers
yes and the presumption is when people
are skiing down a run the people in
front of you aren't going to have that
rear view like you would you'd have
you'd be in a better position as an
overtaking skier to see the people in
front of you
got it
um
three is you must not stop where you
obstruct a trio or are not
visible from above what does that mean
well again it's just about being visible
and so if there's a breakover in the
terrain and you were on the bottom side
of it the skier that's coming from above
isn't going to see you and so it's to
prevent surprises and again if you're
skiing in control if you're following
the first rule when you're coming up to
terrain changes that's one of the things
that skiers have to manage is they're
skiing their their speed their rate
their course and most importantly their
Lookout
that's what allows them if even if they
come to a train change and there's a
let's say a small child taking his skis
off on the downside of that Hill you're
not going to run into him even though
that person might not be following the
code you're not following it either if
you just go tearing over the the heel
you have to be able to be in a position
to maneuver so you don't hit anything
okay so if a skier were
taking are you familiar with the term GS
turned yes giant slower if a skier we're
taking GS turns what principles here
should that skier follow
well with a GS turn and again just
backing up for a moment skiing is very
Dynamic it's people that are changing
positions relative to each other all the
time
and people are going at different speeds
people are using different styles and
you're mentioning one of them you know
short radius turn or slalom versus a
larger radius turn or rounded turn a
giant solemn and these are different
styles and they there's no prescription
for how you have to do it or even what
your ability is any of that there's no
speed limit I mean there's slow skiing
areas but
there's no number so the idea is skiers
have to be able to be in control and
it's the lookout in a GS turn you're
going you're taking wider swaths of
terrain you're moving across more you're
using more of the available heel space
so again if there was
Trail density that was suggesting maybe
used to be skiing shorter radius turns
that would be a reason but typically
when people are skiing giant saw
Insurance their speed is usually faster
and people that are skiing short radius
turns I mean if they try they can ski
quickly but most of the time it's the
turn is what controls your speed so if
you're making more of them you're
probably going slower what about uh if
let's assume a skier is overtaking
another group they're skiing through a
group that's skiing slower what
responsibility is that skier have
well again as the overtaking skier
you're looking at the rule number two
people ahead of you have the right of
way and when you're coming into a group
you now have less space to maneuver and
your Lookout has to be sharper because
you have more things to focus on again
remember everybody's
not moving in unison they're they're
moving dynamically and and people can
turn suddenly and so again if you're a
prudent skier and this isn't necessarily
covered in the code but if I'm going to
make an Abrupt turn on a crowded run
that's a problem for me if I didn't look
I need to look up uh you know it doesn't
say you have to look uphill but so the
the code gets you just so far
and I think
if I may
one of the things about the code is if
you try to look at any one rule and say
for example in a collision because I
have to look at this all the time in
these investigations or when I'm
training people I would have to tell
them never focus on just one that's just
one part of the puzzle there's usually
something else and if I had a penny for
everything that was involved
the failure of the lookout
for example if I have two I might have
two skiers in a collision and both are
trying to be the the
not the uphill skier and I look at them
and I'm going but you were changing your
positions you had different speeds you
were merging and converging on each
other you both have the responsibility
for your Lookout it can't just be
straight ahead you have to be
looking and that's part of why you have
to go to number one and that's the king
and then you go through the rest of them
but you can't hang your head on
just one now in some accidents it may be
uh really prominent and you can weight
it that way but I'm just saying you need
to consider all of this and the lookout
you can't forget right so
um is there anything about
what can you tell us about the rules of
skiing reasonably that relates to skiing
within your ability is that is that one
of the rules well it's not a rule per se
but it is right here that you have to be
in control so that means for whatever
slope you're on whatever the snow
surface might be it might be a hard icy
day and you're going faster might be a
little harder to control your your speed
you know you need to then it's not that
different I guess from driving there
because you know if the weather is bad
and you're breaking distance is bad then
you have to give more room and I think
creating space is is a key but you have
to ski within your ability and you want
to assume that
maybe not everybody's doing the same
thing and and leave a margin okay so
what about if uh take an example of a
skier that may may have certain physical
disabilities
does that skier have the responsibility
to
um take account of those disability or
those limitations and ski appropriately
yes of course
um
let's go move away from this for a
second
um and ask you about a hypothetical
that connects to Dr sure's test me you
were here when Dr sure yes testified or
that was correct and he talked about
bindings releasing do you remember that
yes and do you have knowledge about how
bindings release in this in ski
collisions yes I do so if you were to
assume a certain skier came and hit
another skier directly in the back
um at a high rate of speed would you
expect bindings to
come loose the skis to come off the
skier objection your honor lack of
foundation also not contained in his
report in the lease there is nothing
mentioning any binding release in
anywhere in the report
sustained
let's um
let's try to take another hypothetical
give me a second to think it through
let's forget about bindings let me use
that same hypothetical of someone skiing
directly into someone else's back
would you expect that person
to
launch over the next the the person they
hit in you know a couple feet down the
down the mountain same objection here on
our lack of foundation sustained
is there a space on the hill where
um skiers
um
where you where you should where you uh
think about it differently
if a skier were trying to
avoid collisions and ski in a kind of
safe and cautious place on the hill
where should that skier go
well you could look for uh certainly
train within your ability and if you
want to be cautious you'd probably want
to be on easier runs and if you were
wanting to be away from
more people
specifically if you're concerned about
skier collisions and runs are getting
crowded these days
you know you pick a you pick the right
time or you wait for opportunities you
can wait for traffic to go by and then
you can go staying on the margins of the
Run
is usually good because you only have
one side to defend if you will so if if
a skier were taking short radius turns
on the right side of the Run would would
that be within the
um
parameters you've just described yes
uh I did cut you off a little earlier
when you were talking about the inherent
risks of
skier collisions the things you learned
about what the inherent risks are in
skiing invest investigating collisions I
want to make sure you've got out what
you wanted to on that point was there
anything else well I mean that's a a big
question
sustained
okay your honor may I
okay thanks for your patience
um you personally went to the side of
this Collision correct I did and Were
You There When Mr Brill uh maybe I
should ask first do you know Mr Brian
Brill I do and uh who is he uh he does
animations the ones that you've been
seeing here and uh he he does them all
over uh for ski accidents I think he
does other things too but he's very very
precise in laying out the terrain and
the features in the terrain that you
know the trees are all the right height
and the Shadows are correct and all of
that and you were here and you'd seen
the animations before correct I have
objection your honor this goes beyond
the scope of his report there's no
mention of animations in the report
ruled at this point
how it's tied in sure I was just going
to ask that does the given that you've
been to the site of the Collision does
the animation to you accurately portray
the location
sustained as to relevance it doesn't
matter
it was a demonstrative of the other
Witnesses testimony okay
um
in this case
what did you review
I looked at all the deposition testimony
the documents and various forms we did
the site inspection
I I did work with Mr Brill on the
animations I talked to Mr Speaker strike
relevance sustained as to relevance why
don't we take our lunch break at this
time it's just a little afternoon and
we'll so we'll take a recess and return
at 1 30. thank you your honor
your questions in light of the Court's
earlier rulings
okay we'll see you back at 1 30. thank
you
thank you
foreign
the bailiffs are bringing in the jury
and getting them ready
until they're ready
foreign
Mr Bogger you can come back up to the
witness stand
okay we're ready for the jury
thank you
all right thank you Mr Egan you may
continue
thank you your honor
all right Mr Bogger we just have a few
more questions and then we'll get you
off the stand here
um first uh is it your opinion that both
Mr Sanderson and Miss Paltrow have the
responsibility to exercise reasonable
care
to avoid a collision with each other on
the day of their accident yes that's
correct and if and you're familiar with
Miss Paltrow's account of that Collision
correct yes I am have you heard her
testimony in the trial testimony that
she gave to this jury I have and you
also reviewed her deposition yes and uh
if you assume that her account is
correct
your opinion that she did comply with
the standard of care or this the
reasonable standard that you just said
that was her Duty
yes and if you assume her account was
correct did Mr Sanderson
comply with that Duty
no
and
um
why is that
well if you assume the facts that we're
looking at Miss Paltrow's version
then you'd have to conclude that at the
moment of the Collision
she was a skier below and was hit from
behind and that Collision
I know I said there were a lot of other
factors but in this case that seems to
be the key factor and that's where
the failure of someone's Lookout at the
last minute even if they can be in
control the entire time making great so
all I'm turns whatever it might be
but you can be a very good skier and you
can be skiing in control but if you have
a momentary failure and there's someone
below you of your Lookout
then you have a collision and by
definition if you have that Collision
that's not in control because you can't
stop it or avoid anything below so by
definition that's skiing out of control
even if it's momentary
did you review the
evidence relating to Deer Valley's
paperwork and um
obtaining of information about this
accident I did and do you have
knowledge of the standards for ski
resorts in terms of that kind of a
investigation of an accident yes and did
Deer Valley comply with that standard
yes based on the facts that they had in
front of them yes
and did you see any evidence of
um
inappropriate documentation
no what I reviewed looked like it would
meet the industry standard of care it
would be very similar to all the skiers
that I visited and know I'm familiar
with their record keeping and so forth
these are typical business records kept
in the course of business
in your experience
thoroughly investigating over I think
you said 500 ski collisions do you
sometimes conclude that the evidence
does not allow you to determine who is
at fault all the time yeah you sometimes
you just don't have enough information
sometimes you have conflicting
information and you just you know
there's plausible versions and you can't
you can't know which one's right and you
just have to realize that you're not
going to be able to determine fault so
that's that's common enough
that's all my questions thanks thanks
miss van Orman
good afternoon good afternoon I'm going
to be really really quick with you in
fact we're just going to do the
opposite of what you just testified to
so you were just asked if Miss Paltrow's
version of the accident assuming that
was true would Mr Sanderson have
violated the skier's responsibility code
we're going to flip that you've heard Mr
Sanderson and Mr Ramon's version of the
accident assuming those were true
they would have complied with the
skier's responsibility code correct
correct and Miss Paltrow would have
violated this year's responsibility code
that's correct all right and in fact the
skier's responsibility code it applies
to all skiers they all have to follow it
right that's correct no matter if
somebody has a disability in their eye
or if they're turning to look at their
children to watch them ski
all skiers have that responsibility at
all times that's all I have thank you
thank you Mr Egan
thank you Mr Bogger thank you you may
step down
Mr Egan you may call your next witness
or Mr Owens this time thank you
Stephen Edgeley
MD
do you swear that the testimony you are
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth shall help you
God
thank you you can have a seat good
afternoon
Would You Begin by stating your full
name and spelling it for the jury
that's a s-t-e-b-e-n
-e-d-g-l-e-y
yep
okay Dr edsley are you employed yes
where are you employed at the University
of
Utah and uh are you over the acquired
brain injury
division yes uh Physical Medicine and
Rehab is my specialty and uh I'm not
over uh that uh suction how old are you
sir uh
okay and just background undergraduate
degree where was that
I
studied psychology with a pre-med
emphasis at BYU
um my med school training losing in
Chicago we had Loyola University in
Chicago
and I did a four year residency and a
physical medicine and Rehab at the
University of Utah and then did you go
there did you stay at the University yes
and have been for how many years
um overall
who want he
20. yes okay and do you do you hold an
endowed chair at the University I do
do you teach are you a professor there
I do and you personally had an acquired
brain injury is that true
yes so I had a stroke in 2001.
um
21 years ago
and uh
did that event play a role in your area
of study
he did
um I was initially announced for a
residency training in optimology
actually
um I took a one year off to
deal with the recovery ax box of my
stroke and uh I've been a beacon
Physical Medicine and Rehab residency
training are you board certified in your
specialty I am
you are a physician MD correct yes and
um
do you deal with people other than
stroke people other acquired brain
injuries so um
my practice so I it's a very busy at
practice
95 of my practice
deals with acquired brain injury
and what is that
as opposed as opposed to brain injury
like if a baby is born
with a brain injury
right acquired so uh uh I acquired a
brain injury
encompasses Strokes uh traumatic brain
injury concussions
and
um Myriad of other brain injuries
related to you know surgery
um in the oxygia near drownings
anoxia's Like Oxygen deprivation yes
okay like it and maybe a a child who's
found at the bottom of the swimming pool
rehabilitated brought in and they come
and see you yes
about how many patients have you seen uh
in your career so I I
have let's see uh um I see about
15 separate encounter risks per day over
20 years
that equals over 65
patient Encounters of a quietered brain
injury thank you and do you consider
yourself an expert in brain injuries
yes
and the fact that you have personally
had an acquired brain injury does that
also give you additional Insight it
makes me
um kind of a unique uh you know not that
I have a experienced
have you reviewed voluminous records in
this case I have
so the court complained uh records and
reports from the VA hospital is that
fair yes about a thousand Pages or so
yes and uh deposition transcripts
Gwyneth Paltrow Terry Sanderson
the daughters Sam Goldstein Dr Fong all
of those yes that's correct and medical
records also of the Park City InstaCare
cognitive FX Sam Goldstein
have you reviewed those yes
uh
do you believe that you have the
foundation to render expert opinions in
this case I do
the jurors have already heard
that the patient uh or I should say Mr
Sanderson has
a mild traumatic brain injury do you
agree or disagree
I think I have a poured over the records
um
I I think it's possible
okay
but
uh the
uh you might want to use ARC and
conclusive
did you tell me that uh the most
important things you look at are how
long they're unconscious and how long
they've lost their memory amnesia
that's correct so uh that's uh going by
the Cantu
concussion grading system which is
uh preferable because it's uh the most
objective
and not relying on subjective
to sometimes from any patient okay so a
concussion if so if you hear someone has
a concussion are those that your two
lead questions how long were you out
and how long was your memory out exactly
all right and apply that to Mr Sanderson
would you
so Yeti is uh one nuclear whether he
lost Consciousness now
um
uh let me uh be a clear
so
um
let's say Divine con consciousness
so
when you are unconscious you are totally
lifeless and limp
not speaking not moving
that's unconsciousness
uh I I
based on the
records uh there is a very
unconsistent Africans uh that uh he did
in fact lose Consciousness so I I am not
able to estate that
I can conclusively okay what do we know
about for instance uh
Christensen was the ski instructor he
testified to no loss of consciousness
you with me yep and uh
Brad falchuk has not gone yet
Miss Paltrow has uh Paltrow has stated
no loss of consciousness Craig Ramon did
say loss of consciousness have I sort of
summarized some of the people who talked
about that yeah and uh the uh plaintive
his uh said you know a loss of conscious
is
um five minutes and then again a later
10 minutes okay so Mr Sanderson kept
changing what he was telling people
right I don't know a few seconds five
minutes
and then 10 minutes true yes and I think
uh that is uh why it's uh important to
clarify
loss of consciousness without the
post-traumatic amnesia
so um so
uh the plaintive
will not remember
how long he was
unconscious if he had all
he will remember
the first
memory he had of that event
okay and then Consciousness I heard you
say five minutes and I just want to be
clear uh
one of the ways we rate
uh sort of the severity of the
concussion is
um
very short to no concussion up to five
minutes and then over five minutes so is
that true so do I clarify no loss of the
consciousness
but
uh post
traumatic Amnesia is a
grade one concussion
thank you uh
Whitney Smith I guess was another
provider who said no loss of
consciousness do are you aware of that
testimony I I mean
um I
I don't recall okay Wendy was the
toboggan person yeah okay she asked she
quizzed them I guess but let me move on
okay so uh even under even if Ramon's
testimony is believed
uh that that would put him only in the
second category less than five minutes
yes okay and first category is
essentially no loss of consciousness
okay now let's go to Amnesia applying
what you've learned about Mr Sanderson
how long was his uh Amnesia after the
Collision
uh there is also a very ambiguous and
multiple reports
I so
um
I
hear and uh read uh that uh he had a
conversation with the uh Eric
Christiansen which he does remember
which was you know
traumatic and his opinion so Sanderson
remembers Christensen yelling at him
true
so is that what you're referring to yes
that is the allegation yes okay and uh
he he remembers his friend
uh
Craig Ramon talking to him are you okay
are you okay
true yes okay so what does that tell you
about like length of amnesia
um yet
was
breathe you have at all okay
so you said the two big things we look
at for severity of concussion
is uh
how long they're out and how long they
could forget things
um
yes
and I I will add
um
so
people are experiencing a brain a trauma
have a period of
foggy in this and and yes
uh the plaintiff
I said
quote I Wrong My Bell
I run okay at one point he said I had
I rung my bell I hear you go ahead so I
am not able to say you know so
so
um
yeah it is a problem uh it is likely
that he did have some
a confusion but uh but if
you have
he had no
laws of Consciousness and no post
dramatic Amnesia uh your day came out to
really be a called a concussion all
right fair enough and confusion let's
just talk about that issue
um
he has memories at the actual incidence
I correct
I suppose and I I don't think doctor
that's when you do not answer
uh length of
period of confusion do you remember what
he told the toboggan person Whitney
about whether he
do you know if what Whitney observed in
terms of his confusion level
no
um she she wrote alert and oriented
times for something
that's in evidence I'm asking him now to
comment on it overruled no Foundation
overruled it Miss uh if Whitney the
toboggan person observed no con uh
alert and oriented times for are you
familiar with that term yes and is it
four out of four yes like four is the
best score
yeah
I I want to know what that scale means
please tell me
so uh let's see yeah oriented to a
person
please
uh situation
and
and uh location please time all right
time yes I don't know okay president
plays time
uh situation did you say president
or present no person person
so uh all right and the jury's heard on
those issues so uh that's okay I asked
Terry uh would it surprise you if at the
InstaCare they found no confusion he
said no uh is that consistent with your
knowledge of the events yes
have you seen texts he was sending out
even at the bottom of the hill about
Whitney
I will
go ahead I have uh heard about uh the
text yes all right uh
your opinion that uh if if Mr Sanderson
suffered a concussion and it was mild
it was mild leading
that's overruled go ahead
uh what's uh you know the question again
is it your opinion that if Mr Sanderson
suffered a concussion it was mild
yes yeah and is that based on the things
we've been discussing or are there any
other issues
um
loss of consciousness
Amnesia confusion
I'm just wondering are there other
issues we ought to hit before we move on
to your next opinion
that go to that issue
hey held meant to the lowest velocity
impact
uh also low velocity impact what does
that mean so
he was not a
going fast
okay what do you like
like
in a car accident he was an idea going a
car
okay
and you read for instance the
depositions where they discussed it was
actually kind of a slow fall yes
and that's important when determining
how hard the hit was or something for
the concussion severity yes thank you
any other factors we've missed I don't
think so all right let's go to your
second opinion here
none of the medical records
support
plaintiff's claim
that perceives symptoms of cognitive
decline are related to the ski Collision
is that your opinion
yes maybe I'll flip it around
comment on the his symptoms
uh
what what percentage of the symptoms
that he now complains of are related to
the ski Collision
you can't
I can't tell you I do that I I think it
would be a better to
um
analyze what he had going on his and his
brain before and after how they can to
listen please do that
so um
about the plaintiff in iron
in no way trying to uh pick on
the plaintiff
but
he had a number of uh brain conditions
he had a thrilled which he lost
he is eyesight in his right eye stroke
yes
he had
evidence of a microvascular disease
in his brain uh in his brain
um
and most probably you have most
importantly
he had evidence of a hydrocephalus
a clearer back in 2000
nine and
a lot so uh let me talk about the height
of real selfless in
okay let me make sure we get the whole
list though these are preceding brain
problems from his uh pre-collision true
yeah are we showing this whatever this
exhibit is to the witness and having him
read off of that
no he's not reading off of it but please
turn it around
it's a different topic
go ahead
so that was not a prop that was getting
ready to show it but we'll we'll go on
yeah okay yeah what do you stay yeah
thank you okay I heard you say uh
with regard to pre-collision brain
problems that the plaintiff had stroke
microvascular disease hydrocephalus any
others
um not that uh sewed up on the
MRI of his brain in oh nine he had a
history of migraines is that something
he'd put under that list or not
yes so
stand
okay
um
pardon me I didn't need strikes
I couldn't hear it
motion granted I didn't even know what
his answer was going to be by the way
I was trying to get this list together
but
uh must disregard it thank you so
uh if you think of another one we ought
to talk about please tell me okay
uh
you said you want to talk about
hydrocephalus what is that word
cephalos is uh
we're the
ventricles we have
um
too much pressure
War
um a condition called normal pressure
ice
which is equally uh
kind of a devastating
um for me does hydro mean water yes what
does cephalus mean
um brain Okay so
water on the brain and then this is very
confusing
normal pressure hydrocephalus is not a
normal condition is that true not not
at all over overruled
I mean when I see the word normal in a
diagnosis I think oh that's normal but
in this case
normal pressure hydrocephalus his or is
not a good condition
um it is a well recognized medical
condition
that is
degenerative in nature
meeting it gets worse what the time
about one
only a one in 500
people between now the age
60s 3 and 70 have this
and it gets worse with that time you
said hydrocephalus means water brain
what does that mean there's too much
fluid in the head or what so it
specifically means that there is a too
much a fluid in the ventricles of the
brain and what's a ventricle again
um so fluid field
cavities I've had to feed the
spinal column and
eventually I get
reserved by the body and you said it's
Progressive just comment on that so
let's say there were no ski accident
comment on its progressiveness and Mr
Sanderson
so it's been
14 years since uh that he initially MRI
so that's
quite a bit a bit of a time I would
expect
some Thomas to a crop up like loss of a
memory like
travel with balance
okay
let's move on to
microscular Disease by the way was
I want to know if these things are
related
if someone has the hydrocephalus like Mr
Sanderson does he also have to have
microvascular disease no all right and
do you believe the microvascular disease
caused the stroke
yes okay so those two things are related
so go ahead uh so I.E a stroke of how
the central retinal artery
is a harbinger of
feature strokes and a indication that
there is micro
microfascular disease so microvascular
micro means small mall is that right yes
vascular means like blood flow yes all
right so small blood flow so in late
terms
um
does that mean the passages of blood
flow are narrowed in his brain
yes
I understand I'm trying to get to the
most
like eighth grade level which is what I
understand yeah so comment uh
on on Mr sanderson's pre-collision brain
as it related to microvascular disease
please
so uh two on point so um
some
microvascular disease and I can cause uh
very small stroke
which are
not able to be a detected by
uh scans MRI C
also
a number two uh
um microfascial or red disease
is a
greater risk factor F4
a futurist stroke
do you believe this is is this your
opinion all symptoms
plane of claims
is explained
not by the Collision but by his
pre-accident conditions we
trying to get his opinion out there your
honor
you can ask what his opinion is
yeah uh sustained okay comment on your
opinion on on that issue on the issue of
his his current claims
as it relates to his
um pre-accident conditions
so
and he more likely I have been not
scenario
uh and this 76 year old brain now
uh
concussion some Thomas
should only last for one to three months
there is a wide birth of evidence
yeah that
when the concussion symptoms
last for longer than three months
is
highly correlated with monetary gains or
litigation
explain that please the monetary gains
or litigation go ahead
and related please directly to Mr
Sanderson
was beyond the scope of his expert
report
did you approach please
objection sustained
describe the answer to and the answer
question and answer and then the jury is
ordered to disregard it
comment would you on the patient's
pre-existing anxiety and depression
so
yeah because I've been medicated uh for
a number of years for depression and
anxiety
those things play a role in his current
condition absolutely
just comment on that would you
so
um
also
one sometimes of
concussion
lasts for three months or longer
uh
anxiety and depression and other
psychiatric
conditions on are the likely
cause of that prolongation
the last sentence uh
I missed the last word I'm sorry uh
prolongation prolongation thank you for
explaining that can you just comment
just a little further about that
what do you say a different way for me
would you yeah
yeah so um
symptoms of a concussion should last
manure more than three months
when
the symptoms of concussion last longer
than three months you start looking for
and this is
High highly correlated with
underlining
depression anxiety
and other psychiatric
conditions
one thing you noted in your report was
plaintiff has a history of seeking
medical attention at an abnormal rate 72
times in 10 years is that your opinion
sustained
well comment on how frequently
uh
Mr Sanderson went to his doctors in the
10 years prior to the Collision
so
Dia de note that he had an extensive
history of seeking heck here
and what does that tell you why is that
important
um I have two things one I I either he
has many medical issues
before the Collision were
uh kind of hyper focused on
his symptoms and this pre-collision
we're talking about yes
and then pre-collision
uh
just as a part of aging
did he note a decline in his mental or
physical activity the Acuity level
so
what's an interesting uh
um
is within one month of the acquisition
he I went to uh his own family doctor
and said I am
I feel like I'm getting old this is
within one month before yes
and did he say I'm having a hard time
doing the things I've always done yes
overruled
and why was he why was he feeling that
way do we know yeah I
yeah so I I I'm just asking
do you have any thoughts on that issue
sustained
well using your medical opinion I'm just
wondering uh what does that tell you as
a reviewing medical expert Foundation
overruled
go ahead
I'm getting old and I can't do what I
used to do go ahead so
overruled
so
I have I had many patients of his age
saying how the same thing yes
yes
um
and
I I think um it's important to clarify
one thing so um
the brain is in a working
just liking any other working
with the time he had a cruise
conditions problems
just like
any other organ
uh
the plaintiff
had evidence
including objective evidence of on
MRI and things like that of
this these disease processes
before the clinician okay and this was
the stroke work up is that where he had
the Imaging yeah before and do you know
of any of their plaintiffs experts who
actually reviewed the stroke Imaging
before the Collision
overruled
I do
did they
um are they named the plaintiffs experts
review The Imaging to your knowledge
not to my knowledge
and if we're trying to figure out hey
what's this guy's brain like before and
what's this blame guy's brain like after
it would be nice to put those side to
side wouldn't it and actually compare
it would and
that's yeah that's uh What uh the
defense has done yes all right let's
just talk about aging direct uh
have you seen
may I show him a document in your honor
before I publish it sure
defense exhibit 103
and 103 B
I have and does that appear to be a true
and correct summary of Mr sanderson's
Health before the incident
it does okay and you're on our move to
publish it
in the direction we object your honor
it's it's what we've talked about before
there's a relevant medical information
there
I'm about to establish the relevance if
he hasn't established it yet
um I'm going to admit 103 and 103 B for
demonstrative purposes only to allow
this witness to illustrate their
testimony
can I is this okay for a minute sure
the thing I just don't trust technology
so 103 uh
and doctor do you have a binder right in
front of you
yeah may I approach right
oh can you see it right here yes oh
a monitor
through us the first week that the
monitor wasn't working can can we do the
first uh third
all right can you see that okay Doctor
yes and is this the the note you were
just talking about thinks he's gotten
old
yeah yeah it is yes and then uh let's
stay that big then
blind and right eye were you familiar
with that
I was
and severely impaired in the other did
you see that in his medical records
I did
did you see evidence that he walked into
walls before the incident
yes he would ask people standing on the
right side of his field of vision to
move so that he could see them
did you see that in the evidence yes one
of the reasons he retired was because he
had a stroke event that deprived his Ox
eye of oxygen impacting his vision
Did You observe that in the evidence yes
we're going to go through all these it's
going to be leaning your honor every
time
overruled
He adjusted his skiing at to one side of
the slope to try to avoid hitting others
in his blind spot Did You observe that
yes he had to be picky about what days
he skied to avoid days with lighting
that would further limit his depth
perception do you agree
all right did you see that in the
evidence yes by the way I mean if I if I
close one eye
do I have depth perception is
to comment on that but it's still
three-dimensional or is it now
two-dimensional you do one time yeah
testimony or honor he's calling you
about aging overruled
okay so I'm closing one eye
does that hurt my depth perception or it
doesn't
it does just comment very briefly well
um uh you have I basically uh got a
monologue your
uh situation
um
and so
depth perception will will be a severely
impaired
prostate cancer uh were you aware he he
to this day still has metastatic
prostate cancer yes
it's not like it was cured true
yeah
and he is severely hearing impaired did
you see that in the record yes his
difficulty hearing higher frequency
sounds like a woman's voice did you see
that yes hearing loss is severe did you
see that yes
a heart palpitations did you see
reference to that
yes and he was on two heart medicines
two heart uh just prior to the ski
Collision two blood pressure meds for
his heart yes is that is that related to
the palpitations or are those high blood
pressure issues separate from the
palpitations so
um
can be related to uh the heart they can
be related to anxiety
okay do you have an opinion one way or
the other yeah so I can download
speculate okay Mr Sanderson is 76 years
old and experiencing the effects of
Aging do you believe that
you Doug
we all are
is that a yes uh yes
microvascular disease we talked about
that moderate diffuse volume loss
atrophy brain volume decreasing
did you note that that he had that prior
to the ski Collision so I read Italian
at the report yes and
what does that mean it do our brains all
shrink as we age
yes
um
some more of in others
yeah talk about Mr Sanderson please
brainy atrophy yeah it can be uh caused
by a number of of uh factors
they comment on Mr Sanderson please
um
why did he have that before
ski Collision uh
overruled
you know why he he had it I I don't uh
it's a vague
uh symptom finding
and it could be a cause by number of
things
uh calmingly people who I drink alcohol
excessively
commonly have brain atrophy but but
there are a number of
other causes
see any evidence in the VA record that
he sometimes drinks more than six drinks
a night
did and they did you see his the advice
from his providers was
don't do that anymore
dick we want you to abstain from alcohol
yes
idea to see that yes all right we're
gonna move faster here
by the way it says moderate volume loss
so mild moderate severe are those sort
of the three categories yes
and
that's uh referring it to the MRI in
retinal artery occlusion
we talked about that that's the eye
thing
and
clotting in arteries delivering blood to
brain is there anything you want to
comment that you haven't talked about on
that issue number nine
no no I don't think so impression you've
talked about that anything more you want
to say about it
and depression and anxiety
if he says since the ski Collision I've
had more depression and anxiety than I
did before
uh what do you attribute that to
so
any symptoms
asked three months
I would
tribute
to this
multiple factors not at the uh accident
a migraine we've talked about let's go
we're gonna March through these very
fast
in addition to uh
going now starting on 103 B12
did you know he had degenerative disc
disease in his back prior to the skeet
Collision
I did did you see reference to a foot
drop that he at least for a time he
actually was dragging his foot
I did weakness in his uh back and spine
yes loss of sensation did you see that
yes and just general back pain yes knee
injury yes
yes and that was actually from a skeet
Collision do you recall this not a
collision a ski accident
yes shoulder injury shoulder problems do
you recall him having those
yes and hamstring injury right torn
hamstring yes osteoarthritis did you see
that yes you can
what maybe more relevant to uh this case
is at the Austin arthritis
in at the neck
region which would make
moving your head side to a site kind of
a painful word difficult that along with
the vision impairment
um
are I think relevant
all right uh
my partners here are telling me I should
wind up
uh
can you at least look at insomnia
respiratory problems for male sexual
reproductive Health lower urinary tract
issues kidney problems
hypercholesterolemia
weight gain and restless legs are those
all conditions you saw in as
pre-collision medical records yeah where
are these things important when we're
talking about aging
is a long list
uh
some of the other user conditions are
more relevant than others
but uh the
sum
um
he is
76 and with uh 76 year olds
sometimes I have
multiple medical like conditions like
those and these are all pre-collision
events right pre-collision conditions
yes and what does that tell you in terms
of his his aging
like at 69.
well um
that he was
so I
like I said that before
we all are
aging yes and after
so in the traumas of the brain is in
Oregon
we are talking about
brain Reserve
and we talked about cognitive Reserve
brain Reserve can set you a goal and
down and down
uh starting at around age at 25.
uh it goes down faster
with the time and aging okay a cognitive
Reserve
uh indicates
uh
the patient's ability to cope
adapt
the resilient
and find the effect of work rounds for
that brain
decline which we are all
our
uh underwear going he had a very various
stages let me conclude here they're
about to stand up and criticize you for
not personally meeting with the patient
did you personally meet with Mr
Sanderson no and what did his tree
actual treating providers at the
University of Utah or excuse me the VA
Veterans Administration people
what did they show on their all their
neural psych testing
so
press
and um yeah Hallelujah meet and exam and
the plaintiff because I think it would
be a kind of a conscious ending to a ham
and all too old to me to go over a
totally normal physical exam
as uh the uh
medical doctors
erwva had well documented records and
they normally they documented High
average to Superior and essentially all
categories
stand
can you comment on their findings in
terms of some kind of
graph
yeah I think you're referring to the
neuropsych test correct just give us and
then I'm sitting down give us a couple
two sentences on that would you
so yeah a narrow a psych test is really
uh
like an MRI of the actual mind and its
function and what was it as to Mr
Sanderson after the Collision
uh
he had three
neuropsycho tests and it was
Superior to above the average thank you
yeah those are all my questions and
we'll take a short recess right now
thank you
foreign
you can step down we'll take a 10 minute
break 10 minutes
foreign
thank you your peers and those of your
specialty into the actual definition of
what unconscious means
I don't think so
so all of those that are in your
specialty would say that a loss of
consciousness
um
involves
I don't want to put words in your mouth
but lifeless and Limp is the way you put
it is that correct
yes
so if we've heard testimony before this
that
you can be unconscious or have a loss of
consciousness but still be somewhat
awake just disoriented or not alert
that's not correct
and that's
disorientation not a loss of the
consciousness
okay
is it possible that the Amnesia that you
talked about with
defense counsel is or could account for
Terry sanderson's inconsistent testimony
about how long he may or may not have
crossed consciousness
yes
so that is a that is a very real
possibility in this case
actually uh
you cannot
comment on your own unconsciousness
so so then we would be forced to rely on
the testimony of those that were there
or those that reported what they had
seen yes okay
we've heard some testimony earlier uh
about a triggering event are you aware
of things that could be considered a
triggering event
uh the concept yes okay
is Alzheimer's disease caused by a
triggering event typically
no okay okay is dementia caused by a
triggering event no okay
is NPH caused by a triggering event
no okay
can the presence of mph exacerbate a
concussion or the symptoms I'm in
uh yeah the accounting and Theory but
only uh for a brief Improvement of a
Time brief
meaning
weeks two months not certainly a not
seven years
the jury's heard a lot of testimony
about a condition called PCS or
post-concussive symptoms are you aware
of that condition yes
so is it your testimony that
the presence of NPH could not be a risk
factor in possibly leading to PCS
let me uh I'm back uh so um
you should be aware if you're not
already you know that the DSM-5
which is at the
lust of sake and Rick conditions
um the the fifth and most current
edition
says that
a concussion last uh a more than three
three
look for other causes
and and I I believe that they have a
totally eliminated
PCS from about their
diagnostic manual
so and I don't want to miss that you're
the answer you just gave me but is it
your opinion then that PCS and NPH are
not related at all then
you're asking me uh to a state a
categorical answer
yes
now
I cannot say that there is no
small you know
uh Association
okay so when Dr Bain for instance
testifies that it's rare but PCS can
occur after the occurrence of a
concussion is is that accurate of
testimony
I would like had to so I I have an issue
without the term peace
happy because I don't think it's
so we're as it was he a valid
condition
it's not
uh Elise world
it's not recognized yet he has a
condition now
okay so and maybe I in artfully asked
the question but essentially if I hear
what you're asking or what what your
response was and again I don't want to
restate for you but you're you're coming
at this from a psychiatric perspective
where PCS might be more of a clinical or
medical diagnosis is that correct
no okay
can anxiety and depression be risk
factors for possibly having PCS
uh again I I take ESU without the term
pescs post
discussion syndrome
okay what about and I think we're
talking about the same things but I
believe I'm talking about post-conco
concussion symptoms
and I don't know that they refer to the
syndrome anymore is that correct yes
okay so if I you want to talk about uh
post concussion symptoms
uh we I can I have a dialogue yes and
then and maybe that's my my fault for
misstating it before I'll ask you the
same question then can NPH be a risk
factor for post-concussive concussive
so
NPH is a chronic
degenerative disease
I've had
he has likely a excerbated
by a number of uh things
uh the
immediate yeah for I aftermath of
concussion being one of them
but
more likely much more likely than not
the concussions
symptoms would have long you know years
ago gone away
and what we're left with is
a brain hepatitis
MP
microvascular disease history of stroke
and is
76.
okay and and you said a history of
stroke I want to make sure the jury's
clear uh Mr Sanderson had a stroke-like
event in his eye is that what you're
referring to when you say stroke
uh wait hold me uh be uh clear to uh the
journey so um how the American
stroke and a hard hit Association
um
considers a
red rattling no artery occlusion he has
a historic effect
not a stroke like event a stroke
okay but there's no uh scans and you've
poured over many in this case that show
any sort of brain bleed or or
any issues besides the mph and other
issues that we've talked about
that would be related to that stroke
event is that correct
yes
and did you read anywhere
in the medical records that you poured
over
that he had any sort of
NPH symptomology before the ski crash in
2016.
NPH
symptoms all right yes
what are those I think they're called
the Triads sometimes what are the three
main symptoms of NPH
so
this is a very lame man's way of
explaining it but you have cognitive
deficits
including memory
loss
you will have
imbalance
and uh that again lead that to uh Falls
and you have
urinary
incontinence and continents
loss of the
function of holding urine in your
bladder
so just to recap those those the Triad
is is memory issues Ataxia and then
incontinence is typically how that's
diagnosed correct yes okay and you do
not see any of those symptoms in Mr
Sanderson
before the ski crash in 2016. okay
uh before 2009
and what were those symptoms that you
read well now before
2009 that's it correct but uh yet it was
commenting it on uh the MRI of a 2009
and
given about those symptoms are Insidious
uh in another onset
happening over
years
maybe a dank uh decades
a 14 years later
uh
I I'm not at all surprised
to a fine uh
the plaintiff
experiencing memory and loss of balance
issues
okay did you review any of the MRIs
taken of his brain in 2017 after the
Collision yes and did those MRIs that
you reviewed did those show any sort of
a worsening of this NPH
um the commented on it
I I don't know
if
the
scans showed resume
okay so you don't know one way or
another if it worsened or not but they
did mention that it that condition was
present yes
um
that NPH is a clinical diagnosis
verified by rail Radiology funny things
but nobody had diagnosed his NPH before
as having the Triad that we talked about
before
correct
uh I I now have to see any mansion
yes
and
you were asked a lot about
plaintiff's medical conditions we had a
board up here we had a whole list here
um
did you read anywhere in the depositions
that you reviewed that any of the
laundry list of medical medical issues
that the plaintiff mayor may not have
had before the event kept him from being
a world traveler or on the go or even
skiing that day
the effect to have that um
three weeks earlier
he said he was a primary care physician
I feel like I'm getting old
that is most likely based on uh is U.S
set it that in longer laundry list of
conditions there were
taxing their
no one
condition is that
problematic
about how the complication of there was
a various
conditions new way on
a person
both physically and psychologically
sure
but then if if that is the case Doctor
how do you you reviewed some of the
daughters depositions as you said how do
you account for their accounts of what
happened with their dad directly after
the ski crash in 2016.
I'm not going to make up the excellent
Acclaim that there was not a transient
decrease of function
up to uh three months
but beyond three months at a time what
uh decline he had
was more likely than not already the
ball was already rolling
okay
you testified earlier that you've been
an expert in many cases that have gone
on to litigation do you remember when
you testified of that
yes have any of those cases been ski
crash cases
so this is your first
ski crash related expert testimony
yes
do you know what confabulation is
and what is that will you explain it for
the jury please
uh can that population uh
means making making this
information up
and it's it's not just lying per se
right it's not just you're grabbing it
out of thin air there's a little bit
more of a clinical uh definition for it
isn't that correct
I I don't know we're usually going with
this
was is it's not confabulation is an
actual medical condition it's not just
creating lies correct
and I I can be
related to a medical condition yes
is it often seen in situations where
people have had a brain injury
yes okay
so inconsistent testimony by the
plaintiff
may be attributable to confabulation if
his story is to be believed that he has
a TBI
so uh and to um
point that uh
symptom
Elation to have the brain
enlarged brain injury
sure it's possible
but but
plenty of other things could account for
that symptom of a convulation sure but
it is possible as you just said
yes
from the 2009 to the last scan that you
saw and I don't know when that was
probably the 2017 scan
um
have you seen any of his symptoms the
symptomology that you reviewed earlier
getting progressively worse from an
actual Imaging standpoint
no
um but we're talking about
clinical and diagnosis he's
backed up you know only
backed up
by Imaging
yeah sure well there's no physical you
can't point to any scans that say this
is different than it was in those early
scans in 2009.
now we're what I necessarily expect to
do you know what the medical term
discordant means
uh yeah okay uh
we uh don't uh
often use that
okay and what does it mean
well
it means uh Loosely but things that
don't make sense and don't add up
okay
you've been asked a lot about Mr
sanderson's medical records and
Radiology reports that you reviewed I'm
going to show this first page of
plaintiff's exhibit 6.
do you see this Radiology report right
here
yes okay I want to I'm going to zoom in
here for all for all of us and I've
moved up to avoid the address on the
bottom
sorry about that
you want a Sharpie
do you read that uh that paragraph that
starts with the word findings do you see
that
yes
now will you just read that first
sentence for us right there
and demonstration of a prominent I think
tricky alert system
discordant with mild cerebral volume
loss in the solical
and prominent
now
you have the degrees and I don't so does
that mean that the prominent ventricular
system the issue with that ventricular
system that you described earlier is
discordant or not related to it or
different from the mild cerebral volume
loss
prominence
is that what that means
so
I
I don't I don't so I suppose how do I
get into the brain of Avi and neural
radiologist but uh but that is a
um validate conclusion so that's why
again that's my Layman's approach of
reading a medical record and I recognize
you have that and I respect your
position
but the medical records that you
reviewed
discordant is usually used before
describing this ventricular issue that
you described earlier isn't that correct
I I think um we're talking about to a
separate things uh the enlarged
ventricles and it has a separate issue
uh at the mild cerebral volume loss
and short of going well beyond both of
our expertise and sounding more like an
idiot that I'm sure I already do I think
we'll leave that one there
hmm
but you
these aging conditions that you describe
is it also within the possibility of
medical certainty that you've offered
your opinions
that Terry sanderson's condition could
be in fact related to post-concussive
symptoms
literature shows but but
so I would say much more likely yet than
not
uh
correct
yes that for us anything is that
possible
thank you let me just check with
co-counseling I think that's everything
I have for you
so if other Witnesses reported massive
changes directly after this ski crash in
would you also attribute those massive
immediate changes to the aging process
reinstate the question sure
if other Witnesses
ex-girlfriends and daughters
report massive changes in the plaintiff
after the ski crash of 2016. would you
also attribute their
discussion of those massive changes to
regular aging
is that a complex question
uh he had
distress over very real
rib fractioners
he had a psychological and a physical
symptoms
that
do influence you know what a patient's
Global functioning
uh rep fractures healed
bumps and bruises heal
what we're left with long-term
so
I I don't disagree with the
uh the effect that
people around
the inflated
uh
there are more big changes in his
physical and
psychological function immediately after
the entry
but
now there was
brain related to issues
should have resolved Within
weeks to a few months and what we're
left with
is
he
76 well let's see
uh
69 year old
the time brain with multiple problems
sure
but looking over the medical history
that like you did
you see that Terry Sanderson continued
to try to seek treatment for something
that was going on that he attributed to
be fairly related to this accident
correct
would you say yeah that out that day
medical attention seeking Behavior or
asserted
um
before and and
said by his uh primary care if this
isn't a visit uh the week the three
weeks earlier
and
that was likely a ball about
a ruling so he was interested in his
health before the ski crash you've
testified to that correct
yes so he would be very interested in
anything that he have used he viewed to
be very acutely changed isn't that also
correct yes this will be part of that
pattern to continue going to the doctor
a lot
up until you think that you're going to
get some sort of resolution of your
symptoms isn't that correct
uh I I don't suppose to I know what was
I going on and how they played if some
money okay thank you very much doctor I
appreciate it
out from the back here
last question
what do you perceive to be Terry's life
expectancy going forward
I have no
information to base a pnn on that
thank you doctor
Mr Owens
I'm going to read you what you told me
your opinions are on redirect or on
direct and then I want you to see tell
me if anything has changed as a result
of cross-examination
the compelling evidence is that
plaintiff's concussion was mild and that
he lost consciously Consciousness only
momentarily if at all is that still your
opinion yes plaintiff's post Collision
neuropsychological evaluation shows no
evidence of impairment is that still
your opinion
it is
none of the plaintiff's medical records
support his claims that perceive
symptoms of cognitive decline are
related to the ski Collision
it's at this point yes
another way of saying that is all
current symptoms
are explained by his pre-collision
uh
aging and degenerative diseases
overruled
much more likely and
likely than not yes
yes and you were asked about a new word
confabulation like lying
you were asked about that right yes
did you review the deposition of Jenny
Sanders Sanderson the daughter yes did
you observe she said that her dad would
in fact be dishonest
in order to get money
yes
that's not an Evidence
it is
just overruled
and that he seeks attention and that the
notoriety of this case makes him feel
powerful did you read that
I did
and uh
on our little break you said it's
outrageous he said something was
outrageous that they would assert
something what do you remember what it
was
his current conditions are related to
the ski Collision
uh what's
am I throwing you
uh I'm uh being picking my words very
wisely thank you
the narrowest psyche
uh Netherlands
and uh this uh psychiatric evidence
you have long
evidence to a support
have that one
a
concussion like
this electric uh concussion last over
yeah you know months
uh there is a high concordance rate
with
the patient being
involved in litigation
and
and also media attention
both
of his proper testimony overruled
explained
the post accident
both of which
are hyper real
in this case
hyper real means what
very well uh real
very real what is hyper real I missed it
so uh so it's uh just a a cake
termed
for extremely
you know so extremely real
what is again extremely real
now the factors of
this
litigation
and the factors of the media attention
around
his
concussion case so what have what of
those things is hyper real
what are they doing to him about his
current symptomology well so
I'm trying to understand this response
here overruled it goes to the weight
you gotta down it down for me please
at the fact that this is uh the first
Lego lacchaeus
is yeah ever
televised in Utah
makes it
hyper real
in what way to sander to Mr Sanderson
what is that doing to him those facts
I'm just trying to understand his
culture maybe you could go into a little
bit more of the background behind this
opinion
yeah I'm trying to understand the point
you're making
um and then what it's based on
so you're saying
this very litigation and the media
attention is impacting Mr Sanderson is
that your opinion
overruled as a preface to the question
absolutely okay and then how
so
uh the uh litigation so uh
a lot of money is in play here
and how is that affecting Mr sanderson's
symptoms
so
I'm being told to sit down have a nice
day
Sorensen
just one question for you Doctor uh is
hyper real a medical term no
so that's
has no basis in any sort of medical
literature I would
say
real relevant
okay but again you never
conducted your own psychological
evaluation of the plaintiff correct no
so that would be pure speculation about
his motives or anything like that based
on
a number of
studies and meant analysis of uh
case cases
similar to this so case studies but
nothing directly attributable or
applicable to doctors
studies
uh
so I met a analysis of actual
um how things that are in the medical
literature
great thank you very much
okay you may step down thank you
you ready for your next witness or
should we take our last break
okay we'll take a short recess
short recess thank you
I can see that
karaoke good I
okay we have to figure out who on our
side is going to read the questions
because there's only one additional
reflection that was added by Wayne Owens
we're just going to have the same lawyer
read all of the questions
and I'll respond as karaoke so Noreen
could do it that's what I had
are you good well okay
I think it's nice to have both
of one member from each team
so I have the hard copy are there any
objections
okay I'll follow along if you'll key me
in on where you're at
like rejection calls for speculation I
think I think we're good with everything
okay thank you
we're taking a short break before you
begin
yes one other thing on Dr Richard Bain
on the bottle
we don't know this yet but we would like
to propose that to hit Dr Bain and if
it's okay with the court and we have him
testify it to nine or even 8 30 8 45.
Thursday morning
for a very short rebuttal can we deal
with this at five let's do it at five
thank you well it's hard for us to
propose it if it's not approved and
you mean you're you're uh he's waiting
for the word from you well that's that's
part of it your honestly this week is
his wedding he had an emergency medical
procedure it's his wedding his
daughter's wedding oh okay
he had an emergency medical procedure we
notified the opposing Council about
three or four months ago that he
couldn't do his
attempt trial and so well I'm not sure
when your rebuttal case is but if that's
when your rebuttal cases that's fine we
can come a little early on Thursday
getting back to carry Oaks the witness
how are you going to allocate the time
between the parties
based on the time of the questions that
they asked well so apparently there's
one question for the defense and the
rest of it's for the plaintiff
so whatever however that works out to be
ours was about 15 minutes long they
proposed I think that I'd like to
half an hour or 45 minutes of addition
you had designated her as a witness and
we only wanted 15 minutes if you want to
just let us do our 15 minutes why don't
we do this Council
in response
so let's let's go ahead and change
questionnaires depending on which side
has asked for that question and then
I'll be able to keep track of the time
literally your honor I would say their
time is probably
five minutes of the total are you fine
with five minutes okay then five minutes
of the time we'll go to the defense and
the rest will go to the plaintiffs
okay I wasn't involved
all right thank you
okay
foreign
let's wait for the other side
pretty much
would you like me to go get them your
honor yes okay yes please thank you
are we on the record
okay we're back on the record Council
are present and parties are present Mr
Owens yes thanks
so we're thinking this uh Harry Oakes is
going to go about a half hour
and then we're trying to figure out how
to best use that other half hour sure uh
one option is
well here's the question
how strictly we now have essentially one
full day of evidence left
how strictly are you keeping us to like
four hours each left
strict strict so when you run out of
time you're done
okay so
um
and I'm trying to be mindful of the jury
so depending how much time is left then
we'll call Terry Sanders back to the
stage back to the uh
Pulpit we talking tomorrow no if we have
time before tonight five okay okay
thanks all right ready for the jury
explain to the jury what we're doing I
will okay thank you you want to go ahead
and take your seat yes sir do you want
Square me in did that
no I think not the lawyers will point
out any errors in your reading yeah
what page are we starting on so
um
we are starting the funny thing
okay
great thank you
and who's doing the questioning Miss
abarama okay
impersonating them
use your deepest voice
don't make objections
thank you you may be wondering why why
miss van Orman is seated as a witness
that we are now going to read a
deposition old school style
so the the witness name is Terry Oaks
Carrie
thank you for that correction
that's listed two ways in here Kerry
Oaks and the person that will be reading
Carrie Oaks part is Miss Christian van
Orman and the questionnaire will be Miss
abarama
you may proceed starting on Page Six
Judd would you like me to State the page
number and the line number I think if
you right now just uh whenever you skip
areas tell me where you're going okay
okay which is otherwise we don't need to
do the lines
all right starting on page six good
morning Miss Oaks could you spell
for the record yes it's k-e-r-i and Oaks
is o-a-k-s
and do you know about what year you
started working at Deer Valley it's page
12 your honor
1990 actually that was a couple yeah
about that area give or take a couple of
years
page 16. okay when we talk about the
incident or the ski Collision or the ski
crash or similar words let's just agree
right now that we're talking about the
incident that occurred on February 26
2016 involving Gwyneth Paltrow and my
client Terry Sanderson is that clear yes
okay now I would like to go through some
of the parties to this case do you know
my client Terry Sanderson not Beyond
seeing him on the hill that day
okay have you had any other contact with
him prior to that or subsequent where I
spoke with him or no
okay what about Gwyneth Paltrow how long
have you or before this incident do you
know Gwyneth Paltrow that may have been
the first time that I skied with her
family I don't recall exactly how many
days I skied with them
page 18.
okay one or two ski trips you've skied
with Gwyneth Paltrow correct correct
sorry if you could speak up correct
okay what about Brad falchuk do you know
who he is yes
did you ski with him on the ski trip
that involved this ski crash in what
capacity
I mean did you meet him yes we met him
okay and I understand you were teaching
primarily one of the children with some
of the children is that correct not his
children
okay whose children were you teaching
Gwyneth
and who are they apple is specifically
who I was with
okay and were all of the ski trips with
Brad falchuk and Miss Paltrow's children
they were all on the trips with Gwyneth
Paltrow correct correct
you didn't ski with Brad falchuk or the
children on the trips where Miss Paltrow
was not there correct correct
did you know who Greg ramonis no
do you know who Eric Christensen is yes
how do you know Eric through Deer Valley
we work together
how long have you known Eric since I
don't know the exact amount of years but
most of the time that I've been an
employee here I've known him
page 31.
what did you discuss on the day of the
collision with Eric Christensen in in
particular what what in particular
anything about the collision with Miss
Paltrow and my client Terry Sanderson a
relief that everybody was safe
and who was everybody everybody meaning
both people who collided
Miss Paltrow and Mr Sanderson yes
page 53
so just before the ski Collision please
describe what was happening had you all
met at the top of Flagstaff Mountain for
example yes we were we got off the
chairlift decided that we were going to
go down to lunch and can I interrupt
when you say we got off the chair Clift
who is we again just so we're clear
the we would have been Gwyneth apple and
I were on the chair lift I believe that
Eric was with Moses then we met up with
Brad and I cannot remember exactly where
the where his kids and their instructors
were they may have been down already
having the table for lunch so we decided
to go ski down bandana to the Empire
Lodge for lunch then as we started
skiing down bandana it was not crowded
at all there was really nobody on the
run and Moses and apple wanted their mom
to watch them you know wanted to do this
the the side of the run and she could
see she could see them ski so we stopped
to cross the run the Run was clear there
was nobody in front it was it stands out
in my mind because that's a rarity
bandana was fairly it was empty where we
were and so we had just crossed the run
and as I I mean as I looked before we
crossed the Run uphill there was it was
fairly there was really no one in sight
except farther up by a slow sign from
where we were and we crossed made two
turns and then I heard the sound and
looked over and that's when I saw that
they had collided and we were both on
the snow
what was the sound you heard
just I heard her voice and that's what
caught my attention
so I want to just go back over this
slowly just go to 56.
oh sorry
you inserted a word
that inadvertently I apologize
then I heard the sound and looked over
and that's when
saw
that they had collided and were both on
the snow
go ahead and just read the rest of the
page that's fine
and what was the sound you heard just I
heard her voice and that's what caught
my attention
so I just want
to just go back over this slowly you
started skiing down bandana without
apple and Moses correct
still on 55. okay
you want to ask that one more time sure
so I want to just go back over this
slowly you started skiing down bandana
without apple and Moses correct and
gweneth and Eric correct
and you said you crossed the Run was
that near the top of the run near the
top of the Run
when you say you cross the Run does that
mean you went skiers left yes we were on
skiers right and then we had slowed down
or actually I believe we might have even
stopped enough that we were in a group
and then I looked up hill before we
crossed just to make sure it was safe
and then the kids and Eric and I crossed
the Run
to the left to the left to skiers left
and where Eric and you above apple and
Moses when you did this I was he was
behind he was above Hill and I was more
to the side and a little above Hill
and then what happened after you started
Crossing to the left we crossed to the
left and started skiing down the side
and then we heard after as I said two
maybe three times heard the sound of it
was more Gwyneth sounded surprised it
was like a surprise sound and you know
we looked over and they were both on the
ground
when you started to cross to the left
did Miss Paltrow then go straight down
to the right is that what she did she
stayed on the right but she did not go
straight
were you able to see her while you were
watching apple and Moses yes I was able
to see her
how was she skiing she skis small radius
turns consistent speed at this point in
time it was slow because she wanted to
be able to see the kids they were not
skiing fast because the kids are not
fast
was she then going to stop and look up
or was she going to look to the left do
you know she was not going to stop
because we were skiing
okay is it your understanding Miss
Paltrow was going to look to the left
while she was skiing to her children's
skiing
no I cannot say what she was going to do
she was they were in her sight and we
were all the goal was to ski down to the
lodge for lunch
when did the topic of Miss Paltrow
watching her children come up
it
watching her children ski
when did the topic of Miss Paltrow
watching her children ski come up it was
mommy watch me and we want to go ski
this and she and so we we took them to
the side it wasn't a detailed plan on
how she was going to watch it was just a
plan to ski down to the lodge
okay and when Eric Moses apple and you
started skiing to the left was Miss
Paltrow skiing on the right correct she
was skiing on the right
page 68
was Miss Paltrow agitated she when she
was first getting up because she was
very surprised and shocked because that
was her comment was that that he hit her
what was her comment her comment was
that she was hit and was frustrated but
then as she got up and she then she
checked on him
he checked on her everybody was quite
calm nobody was agitated or yelling
when did she ski off Miss Paltrow I
don't recall exactly I believe she was
there for most of the time and yeah she
was there for most of the time I think
that when we had the verbal when it was
verbalized that everybody was okay Mr
Sanderson verbalized to us that he was
okay he was fine and that was his
response to her checking we checked ski
patrol checked and so then at that point
in time you know that's when she just we
said okay let's start we can start
dispersing because everyone expressed
and we were acting as if they were just
fine it was just a collision no harm no
foul
earlier you mentioned that Mr Sanderson
got up do you recall anyone helping him
get up
wow we were there both Eric and I were
there to help him I don't recall that he
he didn't need us to lift him off the
snow I don't recall needing to give much
assistance but we were there for both
parties to help them both and make sure
they were both okay to our abilities and
then assess him from then we would
assess if there was the need for ski
patrol to be called but they happened to
ski by and check themselves
page 71
and why didn't you write an incident
report that day I because nobody to our
knowledge nobody was hurt everybody left
the scene on their own volition and
their own everybody was able to leave
and it was again like just any other
incident where people you know got
tangled up and everybody was okay and
everybody left and so
page 82.
did Gwyneth Paltrow say she didn't see
Terry Sanderson before the Collision
she did not use that I mean he wasn't in
front of her so she he was not in front
of her but she didn't use that phrase
she said he hit me
you're assuming she was in front of him
correct I saw that there was nobody in
front of her when we were skiing and so
that that's not an assumption I there
was nobody on the hill with us in our
immediate vicinity
page 106.
Miss Oaks just before the Collision
Gwyneth Paltrow's children Moses and
apple wanted her to watch them skiing
correct yes we were skiing together down
the final run down to lunch
Miss Paltrow was skiing down to the
right looking up at her children to see
them skiing correct she was skiing down
on the right side her children were in
her periphery
one more time to what page we're on sure
now we're on page 107.
starting on line 14.
so she was looking over at the kids to
see them ski I can't say exactly where
she was looking they were in her
periphery she could see them while
looking ahead to ski
so miss Paltrow was distracted looking
at her children while she was skiing
just before the Collision
I would not say well I can't say that
she was distracted
was Miss Paltrow looking at her kids
while she was skiing down bandana run
when I saw her she was looking ahead at
the run in front of her
was she also looking at her children
skiing I did not see her looking at her
children
so miss Paltrow was distracted when the
Collision occurred looking at her
children correct
she's not looking at her children when I
saw her she was looking ahead skiing
down
so she wasn't watching her children is
that what you're saying yeah I didn't
they they were in her periphery I don't
know what she was looking at directly I
don't know that she was looking at them
directly she was looking ahead where she
was skiing when I saw her
at the moment of the Collision though
you had not seen her for three to five
seconds correct probably three to five
seconds
so you don't know where she was looking
other than she was supposed to be
looking at her children right
I don't know exactly where that she was
looking directly at them I do know that
when parents ski with their kids it
doesn't mean their eyes are glued on
their kids they can glance at them they
can see them in their periphery and as
long as the kids know the parents are
there and they're in their visual that's
what the kids want I don't know exactly
what she was doing the children were
satisfied
Moses and apple wanted their mother
Gwyneth Paltrow to watch them ski down
bandana correct
that's what they had said watch us ski
this Mom okay that was the conversation
page 111. okay and then maybe you
already answered this but in that when
you last Saw Miss Paltrow the three to
five seconds before the scream Did You
observe whether there was anyone below
her on the ski hill
I observed that the area in the front of
her was empty
I think that's it
111.
and that that's it okay
thank you
you may
right
Mr Owens you may call your next Witness
could we have a quick bench conference
here yes
foreign
okay the parties have stipulated a fact
and it looks like it will save us some
time
um Mr Brad falchuk
who may or may not testify later
depending on how much time there is left
in the case
the parties have stipulated that he
would testify where he worked were he to
be called as a witness that he did not
see the accident
is that correct from the plaintiffs yes
from the defense
did the court correctly
I believe so
um
he may or may not be called if there is
time thank you all right thank you and
you're and and so we'll now move to the
defendants have a deposition to read
yes we're going to try to get to the two
kids depositions first
well the March version Moses
so we're gonna have a we're calling
Peter as a fake Moses to the stand okay
so Peter will read Moses
I don't think I have a marked copy
and I'd like the lawyers to each read
their side of the questioning so that we
can capture the minutes used by each
side I just need to get my copies back
that I gave to them what if we uh
because we don't have two Mark copies
because we're doing this on the Fly
but if we
uh we'll read out uh Moses all the marks
apart and you read Apple all the marks
that's fine let's do this
thank you
yes
oh that's right
that's right there they're not
you know what you better
just in case
okay this is kind of weird but I'm the
questioner and you're Moses correct
do you recall how old you are at the
time
thank you page seven it's
just page seven
line 22. do you recall how old you are
you are were at the time nine okay I'm
turning the page
we're gonna back up because there's some
gray
could you just spell your name for the
record
protected
okay so we we all stipulate this was is
Moses Martin
I'm on page seven
as you know we're talking about this ski
Collision that occurred about four and a
half years ago are you familiar with
that yeah
yeah and I'm gonna pick up where I was
do you recall how old you were at the
time nine
okay and you recall this ski trip in
February of 2016 correct yes about four
and a half years ago correct yes
okay you recall skiing that morning that
your mother was involved in this ski
Collision correct yes
I'm now turning the page to page nine
at the bottom
okay
when this ski Collision occurred do you
recall where you were at the moment the
ski Collision occurred I do not recall
where I was at the moment it occurred
do you see the ski Collision I did not
see the actual Collision okay so let's
just start maybe at the beginning of the
run you got off a chair lift correct yes
and the run is called bandana are you
familiar with the bandana run yes
okay at the time of the Collision did
you or just
before the Collision occurred you were
skiing from the top is that correct yes
and who were you skiing with from what I
recall my instructor Eric
page 11 line 22 and you were skiing with
Eric as your ski instructor just before
the Collision correct yes and do you
recall who else was skiing with you at
that time no
was your sister am meaning Apple nearby
yeah
do you know where she was in relation to
you on the hill no
no could she have been below you yes
you don't recall seeing your sister not
exactly
tell us what happened on the bandana run
just before the Collision what do you
recall
I recall ski
skekied over and I followed him
and I saw my mother and a person behind
her that he had crashed who had crashed
okay did you hear a noise before the
Collision no and the person behind her
was that a man yes
moving to the top of page 13. was this
person uphill from your mother yes how
close were they your mother and this
other man
as I recall decently close
let's just say you know this close you
know
see my hands they're about a foot about
14 inches apart or were they further
apart
I'm not 100 sure were they touching each
other I do
was your mother was her head above her
skis so her head was uphill and her skis
were downhill yes
and the man that was nearby her
were his head in where was her his head
in relation to hers
or to his body was his head uphill or
downhill uphill
so I'm just gonna go back a little bit
so when did you first realize your mom
was involved in a collision how did you
realize that I realized the equipment
that she was wearing because I know that
she wears what she wears when she skis
and then I
realized
realized that it was my mom so I was
standing around I realized that it was
my mother
and did you hear a noise that told you
there was something going on a commotion
or anything
when I skied over I heard my mom yelling
at the guy what was she saying she was
saying something along the lines of what
the f word you just ran into me
and anything else that you recall at
that moment no was she standing up when
she said that I do not fully remember
but I
bet okay did she get up by herself I do
not remember
I'm just going to go back in slow motion
to let's say three seconds before this
Collision occurred you were skiing with
Eric
if you're facing downward skiers left is
on the left side and skiers ride is on
the right side
do you know which side you were on the
hill just before this Collision occurred
I was on the left side
do you know how far on the left you were
no
do you think that
but Farish
okay
were you closer to the left edge of the
ski hill I believe so yes and do you
recall anyone else on the hill at that
moment I do not remember
were there other skiers on the hill yes
yes about how many I'm not sure
so what made you ski over to your mother
was it did someone tell you
I was following my instructor but I did
not know what was going
on so you fall you followed your
instructor over to where your mother and
this other man were lying down correct
yes
that scene you know your mother and this
man laying down what else what else do
you call
[Music]
of the man that was uphill from her and
I recall that they were both on the
ground at the time that I skied over
about how far away do you think they
were I do not call about a foot maybe
I'm asking how far apart your mother and
the man were when you skied over there
but maybe more were they touching I do
not remember and do you remember your
mother getting up yes but not for a
while
okay how long was a while like you know
five or ten seconds I'd say two minutes
maybe
and how did she get up
to get up by herself I
did someone help her
I remember do you recall large man
next to the ski Collision location I do
not remember
you said there were some other people
there what do you remember I remember
seeing a few people not a lot but maybe
three people not in including my
instructor
so there was your mother the man that
was involved in the collision and then
there was your instructor were there any
other people I
how many other people do you think I do
not
like was there one or two or three or
four maybe I do not recall and then what
did you do after you skied down to your
mother
I stood there wondering what was
I remember it
and who is we
um as I remember it was being me and my
instructor and I'm not sure whether my
mother
with us so you skied down with your
instructor to the bottom yes of the hill
to lunch
so you skied down the hill with your
instructor Eric Christensen yes anyone
else ski down with you I do not remember
just before the Collision your sister
was somewhere in the area skiing with
you I believe
I believe anyone else in the area I
don't know I don't remember
Jerry call Apple Apple ski instructor
do you recall her being present the ski
instructor for Apple
do you remember Apple ski instructor's
name being Carrie Oaks Carrie I believe
so so was anything said when you came
down to the Collision site where your
mother and this man were
my mother said to the guy what the f
word you just ran into me
and then anything else that you recall
not that I recall were people talking I
believe so was the man talking I do not
remember
when I say the man
I mean the man that was involved on the
ground
or the snow next to your mother I think
it should be on the snow next your
mother correct what do you when I say
the man next to your mother the person
that was involved in this key Collision
yes
so that's I do not I don't
I do not talking or not or not okay do
you remember if your ski instructor Eric
Christiansen was talking I
did anyone beside your mother say that
they had seen the Collision
do you remember talking about the ski
collision at the bottom of the hill
vaguely what do you recall my mother's
saying that she got hit or ran into
you said you went to lunch afterwards
correct yes did you discuss the ski
collision at lunch I believe so what do
you recall not much
who was at lunch with you after the ski
Collision
the day of the Collision have you talked
about the skeet collision with anyone
anyone else you've talked to about the
ski Collision I don't
do you think you might have talked about
it with some other people
I don't remember
I'm now on page 25
when you ski down to the Collision site
before you left did you notice any ski
patrol or medical people come by I do
not recall
do you recall any other people in green
uniforms at the Collision site besides
your ski instructor I did not
before the ski Collision do you recall
saying something to the effect of hey
watch me ski no
have you ever said something like that
no
after the Collision this is bottom of
page 26 after the Collision when you
were watching your mom and this man on
the ground did Eric appear angry at all
not at all was he yelling raising his
voice shouting anything along those
lines no no not at all
why are you so sure it seems like your
memory is a little faded in some areas
which is okay and understandable but I
want to know why you're so sure about
this
how so what stands out to you he tried
to find out what
well and try and see how he could help
everyone without I was tried he tried to
help everybody get out of the situation
safely and yes
do you remember anything specifically he
said not specifically
I think plaintiff's council Lawrence
asked you some questions about they were
sort of vague about what
have you seen
said hey watch me ski maybe a better way
to put this question have you ever told
your mom hey Mom watch this before you
decide to do something on your skis
if you'd like her to watch you ski I do
not recall saying things along the lines
of that
did Eric help your mother stand up I did
not remember do you remember Eric
helping up the man that was involved in
the Collision I did not remember do you
remember skiing down with Eric after you
left the ski site I don't I don't know
if it was exactly Eric but I did ski
down alone I did not ski down alone
okay how close were you to Eric as you
skied down towards your mother
when you realize there was some
commotion or incident close I I skied
closely to him and then you stopped near
your mother yes and then how long after
you stopped did you ski down was it like
a minute or two I did not exactly
remember my best guess would be
somewhere along the lines of two or
three minutes
so you were standing there about two or
three minutes you think I think
I think that completes the questioning
your honor thank you
you may call your next Witness
uh
do you want to play Apple and you
was going to read another deposition of
Apple
okay with you guys the places do it
can you just spell your name for the
record please
oh sorry page 11. line 13.
protected identity
and your last name protected identity
okay you understand that this is a
lawsuit involving a ski collision at
Deer Valley and on February 2000
February 26 2016. are you aware yeah
yeah microphone more toward the center
of the two of you thank you
okay page 12 line three
okay and do you recall this event back
in February 26
2016. yes
okay how old were you back in 2016 were
you
11 no 12. about 11 or 12. yeah yes
okay what were your skiing a bit what
was your skiing ability at the time
intermediate beginner okay
somewhere in between about how many
times have you skied approximately for
this date in February of 2016. four
times
page 15 line 10. okay and do you
remember your ski instructors on that
trip
yes we had Carrie Preston and then my
brother's instructor who I can't
remember the name of and one more female
instructor that I also cannot remember
the name of
page 16 line seven okay that morning do
you remember skiing with which
instructor Carrie
okay and your brother was skiing with
another male instructor I think you said
correct yes
I'll just represent you that his name is
probably Eric Christian Christensen does
that refresh your memory yes
17 first line
okay
so do you recall that the morning of
February 26 2016 when you were skiing
with Eric and apple or in Moses and
yes
Carrie where where had you been skiing
that morning before the incident with my
client
we were on the Mountain at the hotel and
that we were at it was a ski and ski out
type of thing we were mainly on the
greens and Blues do you know about how
many runs you had skied before the
incident
five or six I'd say and were you skiing
with Carrie that whole time yes
was your mother skiing with you at the
same time yes did your mother ever ski
different runs when you were skiing with
Carrie
I don't remember
okay your brother Moses about what level
is he is is he as a skier beginner
okay now I'd like to go to the bottom
before the ski Collision that's subject
to this case Okay okay so you were at
the top of the ski hill and I've waved
the run as bandana do you recall the
name of the Run
yes it was bandana and why do you know
it was named bandana it was our favorite
run
page 19.
and you remember the ski run because
it's your favorite run correct it was
yes it was also the run you go down to
the hotel you were staying at yes okay
next I'm going to ask you
what you recall happening on that run
but before do you recall the ski the ski
Collision
I did not see it but I recall the events
fall
okay well what was going on during the
time just before just before the ski
Collision
we were on our way to lunch at the lodge
and who were you with I was with my
instructor my brother my stepfather my
mother my step siblings and their
instructors
but we were all a bit scattered on the
run so some of us were in front others
were trailing behind a bit more and who
is with your group
I was ahead with my instructor my
stepsister and her instructor
was Brad falchuk with you no
sorry that's page 20.
so just to clarify at the time of the
Collision there was you Carrie Oaks your
ski instructor
there was a if and then there was if's
instructor who we don't know whose name
yet and then there was also your
brother's instructor Eric Christensen
and then there was your brother Moses
correct
yes but I was not with Moses and Eric
they were a little up the run I was all
I was closer to the lodge at the time
about how far away were you from your
brother Moses as you recall before just
before the Collision
I would say I was
I don't really know how to say it I was
further down the Run they were in the
middle of the run I was towards the end
with my stepsister I was not with Moses
or my mother
did you know when the Collision occurred
not the exact time no did you hear
something before the Collision I don't
remember did you hear a scream I did
hear some commotion but I was further
down so I decided to continue to go down
to the lodge okay so when you heard the
commotion is that what you think is the
Collision yes
and when you heard that commotion did
you look anywhere
I don't remember
your mother after you heard the
commotion again I don't remember so I'd
like to know just a just a couple
seconds before the collision and then
the couple of seconds after the
Collision so only about five seconds of
time so you heard in so you heard
something a commotion right yes and then
you did and then did you see anything
I don't recall if I had seen anything or
not I think that I did but I don't
remember okay and when you heard that
commotion you're with karaoke instructor
right yes
and where was she in relation to you was
she above you or below you I believe she
would have been in front of me that is
usually how we skied she would lead me
around 23 now
okay so the five seconds around the
commotion that you believe was the
Collision you were with Carrie Oaks and
if and then the three seconds afterwards
what did you do at that point
we continue to ski down to lunch
and did you know at that time that there
was a ski Collision no when did you
first learn that there was a ski
Collision
when my mom had arrived at lunch after
we had gotten there about five minutes
after and how did you learn about the
ski Collision my mom told me she
she was very
she told us what happened what did she
say
she said she came in and she immediately
I noticed that she looked a bit shocked
and I asked what had happened and she
said this a-hole ran into me he ran
right into my back and I remember she
did this motion saying that he ran into
her back and they both went down
but I I remember that's what she said
24.
so let's go back to the moment of the
Collision or the commotion you heard you
heard the commotion you didn't see the
Collision but you continued to ski down
did yes did karaoke ski with you I
believe so yes and she skied with you
down to the bottom
down to where we were eating yes
okay and when I say the bottom I mean
the bottom of bandana run which is where
The Lodges and uh yes eating places are
is that clear yes
so after right after the commotion
karaoke's if and you ski down to the
bottom of the bandana run correct yeah
and who is at the bottom of the run when
you got there
I don't remember I just know that we
were meeting everybody to eat okay at
the I'm sorry to keep going back to the
commotion did you see anyone else on the
ski run at the time of the commotion
well there were other people skiing but
again I don't really I didn't really pay
attention to what happened I just heard
um some sort of screaming going on above
me but I continued to ski down and I
don't remember if I turned around or not
okay did you recognize the screaming
whose voice whose voice was it it
sounded like a woman but we were so far
down I didn't I couldn't really put
anything to it it wasn't very clear okay
how soon after you got to the bottom did
your mother arrive I would say five to
ten minutes
so you were waiting for her at the
bottom yes and what about Brad falchuk
was he with your mother when he arrived
at the bottom
I believe so did he arrive sooner than
she did
I don't remember well I'd like to go
back to the commotion and just let you
continue into and tell us to the best of
your memory what happened so you heard
that so you heard the commotion and then
what happened and then we continued to
ski down and we got to where we were
eating lunch we started to take off our
gear and then sat down and then shortly
after my mother Brad falchuk my brother
I can't remember if my stepbrother was
there or not but everybody else followed
in after I had arrived
who is everybody else
to the best of my ability I'm pretty
sure it would have been my mother
my little brother Moses Brad falchuk
I would say one or two more instruct
instructors and my stepbrother BF okay
do you recall which ski instructors were
there
again I remember
um Carrie my instructor Preston who
skied with BF and if
Eric and I believe that there was one
more female instructor but I can't fully
recall okay do you recall anyone else
besides the people you've mentioned at
the side of the commotion
no
we're on 27.
so when you're at the having lunch with
the ski Collision discussed at lunch
and what do you call about that
discussion my mom was explaining what
had happened saying that a man ran into
her back and they both went down and she
was in a State of Shock and she decided
after that she was not going to ski for
the rest of the day which she never does
she always stays on but she decided to
get off because she was in shock and she
was in a bit of pain did Carrie Oaks say
anything
I believe there was a conversation
between them I don't recall what it was
about but it was probably about my mom
getting off the mountain okay do you
recall anything else
I recall getting back onto the mountain
for a couple more runs and then I got
off the mountain and I think that my mom
was getting a massage okay when you got
back on the mountain after lunch who
were you skiing with I was skiing with
Carrie anyone else
um I don't remember maybe my stepsister
do you recall skiing with mm I don't
remember okay were you concerned about
your mother at the time yes what was
your concern
well she
I never see her really like shaking up
like that and she was very clearly
visibly upset and she had some sort of
pain I can't remember what but she was
in a little bit of pain and I remember
that's why she went to the spa to get a
massage
did you discuss the ski collision with
anyone after you left lunch I think that
my step siblings and my brother and I we
talked about it because my brother was
closer to the collision and he had also
said that he skied into her back and
they like both went down together this
this Moses can you tell us more
specifically what Moses said
well Moses was Moses was kind of telling
us what had happened I don't know if he
for sure saw it but I know that he was
with people that saw it and so they had
told him what had happened and that it
was what he said
that my mom got hit in the back oh what
did he say again
he said that my mom got hit in the back
and their leg like she went they both
went down together after somebody had
skied into her into her back
we aren't 30. okay when you finish
skiing did you discuss the ski Collision
yes with
him I believe we talked about it at
dinner and after just I was checking in
with my mom to make sure that she was
okay and what did you discuss I asked
her how she was doing how she was
feeling she said she was in pain again I
don't remember where exactly but she did
say that she was in pain she had gotten
a massage I believe so this was around
dinner time and we had just kind of gone
over what had happened did she say
anything about my client Terry Sanderson
she had earlier in the day immediately
not immediately after but after five
minutes after we all met at lunch she
said that
um he had skied into her back and she
called him an a-hole who had skied into
her back anything else you can recall I
remember she was very frantic about it
so she probably said something along the
lines of that but that would be all that
I remember to the best of my ability 31.
okay when you discussed it with your
mother and you said she was frantic what
do you mean by that
she was in a State of Shock she was just
she was very upset and she was in pain
since that collision had you have you
seen your mother in that State of Shock
like that since that not no not like
that she under so you discussed the ski
Collision that night at dinner and do
you recall you were staying at a hotel
suite or something
yes we were in a hotel
the next day to your call what you did
I believe we skied in the morning I
can't remember if we had left that day
or not I the next day
I don't I don't really remember much
33. and do you recall how many ski
instructors were with you at the time of
the Collision when you started skiing
again I believe either three or four
and one was Carrie yes and one was Eric
Christensen yes
was another one Preston yes was there
anyone else you that you recall
I believe that there was one more person
but I I can't be too sure about that
okay did anyone tell you they had seen
the Collision
I don't think so no other than your
mother no
35. okay earlier earlier I think that
you said Moses and said other people had
definitely seen the collisions do you
recall saying something like that
I don't think that I said I don't think
that I said that what do you recall
Moses saying I remember him sort of
telling what happened I don't know that
he was I don't know if he saw it or not
like saw the actual Collision but I know
that he saw my mom on the floor
um I believe I said that he saw my
um I believe I said that he saw my mom
on the floor but I don't think that he
saw the actual Collision okay so after
the commotion or Collision you you skied
down to the bottom of bandana run
correct yes but again I I personally
didn't see the Collision okay but you
heard this commotion yes did someone say
to you ski down to the bottom after the
hit of the Hill after the commotion no
we did not think anything of it we
continued to ski down I don't even know
if we stopped the we included includes
karaoke yes
did anyone ask you to wait by the side
of the Hill after the commotion no I
don't remember that we
I don't I don't know
that you recall do you recall seeing
anyone going to to help your mother
after the commotion
I again did not see the aftermath I had
continued to ski down but I believe that
people did help her and what makes you
believe that because I assume that she
would have needed help up and she was
close to her boyfriend Brad who is now
her husband at the time and both my
brother's ski instructors and I believe
BF ski instructor so I'm assuming that
they would have helped her but Carrie
Oaks stayed with you down to the bottom
of the skied with you stayed with you
down the bottom of the hill yes what
about Eric Christensen
do you recall what he was doing after
the
I believe that he was with my brother
who was near my mom
so he was near the Collision
okay and do you recall which side of the
Hill you were on let's talk about skiers
left and right that means that if you're
skiing downhill the left would be the
skier facing downhill to their left and
the same on the right do you do you know
which side of the Hill you are on ski I
don't I don't remember okay do you think
he might have been in the middle of the
hill or the side or the near the edge of
the Run bandana I don't remember
39.
can you be sure exactly that Carrie Oaks
didn't stop and help your mom after the
question or do you remember that at all
I don't remember I'm I think that we
were further down because I know that we
got to lunch first so I don't I don't
remember okay
I don't think so
do you recall before the commotion on
bandana run saying something to the
effect of hey watch us ski down the hill
no do you recall if Moses said something
like that no you recall if any of your
other people in your group like if or BF
say something like that I don't know
okay I'm just going to show you
something here real quick do you
recognize the person on the left there
that's scary that's that's Carrie Oaks
yes
42. so Carrie Oaks was recently deposed
apple and she actually has specific
memories of being on the scene of the
Collision would you defer to her
testimony of specific memories rather
than sort of your vague memory that she
has with you
yes I could have easily been with
another instructor I believe if had an
instructor
Lawrence I think we have a picture of
Eric can he
which has a picture of him on the cover
of it he looks
a little older than he did
oh he's isn't he the one oh my God I
remember him so well he was the best
oh my God he was the best he just
he would give us can candies and he
would tell us
yes that's Eric would you say he was
under 50 years old I don't remember
I never really skied with him so I never
really saw his face
that's the end of it judge
we're ready willing and able to testify
in person on Monday morning
before we address that after I excuse
the jury okay
we're going to I'm going to excuse you
now until tomorrow morning at nine
o'clock I will recess please do not
discuss this case with anyone including
other jurors please do not attempt to
learn anything about the case outside of
the courtroom including from other
jurors
please avoid radio TV internet
and newspaper reports on this case
please keep an open mind throughout the
presentation of the evidence and finally
please do not form or Express an opinion
on the case until such time as it is
finally submitted to you for
deliberations
have a good evening
okay Mr Owens what was it that you
wanted to put on the record
I would always prefer live testimony to
reading transcripts but the kids were
not available
and uh
mostly I just want to put that on the
record I was expecting to take over the
case on Monday morning given multiple
assurances that I could do so and I was
not able to do so
the multiple assurances were if we're
done and we intended to be done it
sounds like some kind of a
statement that we didn't do something
we're supposed to do and they took
almost as much time cross-examining more
on some of these Witnesses and that's
why we didn't finish
okay you could you could have called
them live if you still can call them
live
but I understand that you wanted to put
that on the record so thank you
unavailable
all right
um so we're going to take a short recess
maybe five minutes and come back and
work on jury instructions is that right
okay just take a quick bathroom break
and we'll be right back and hopefully
we'll wrap it up by the end by half past
the hour
nine what time would you like everybody
here
845 be ready to go because once all the
jurors are assembled we can start
perfect
foreign
thank you